[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
hey guys it's me dunk and welcome back
to the dragon ball fighterz tenkaichi
online master challenge for the world
championships we just had us west go off
last week i believe scientific
scientific kof took it uh for them but
right now we are going to be going
through europe for it should be a good
battle between these players and i've
got none other than my wingman c4 iq to
help me run down this top eight c4 how
are you doing this evening
i'm all right man feeling good about
this man like the trailer pulled back
some memories feels like a lifetime ago
man but uh
we're here this is just the start of the
championship so i'm excited obviously to
move you you start from the bottom now
we're here
where we're gonna be calling some shots
for some good dragon ball can't wait man
i mean this is all this is where we
started where we had
you know a lot of events
online and now we're here on the big
stage to watch people hopefully to
progress to that offline stage um i
think we can look at the top eight
remember this is europe four so i
believe the regions are germany denmark
norway and sweden and boy this top eight
is germany stacked you guys can see it
right here so many germany german
players are dominating the top fight
we've got pon cake and alexia as the
sole representatives from denmark and
sweden but let's run through this top
eight right now we've got panda and
jonas
fighting in our first match poncake and
alexa going up second pancake actually
from croatia but fighting out of denmark
he's going to be going up against alexia
who's representing sweden and then over
on the loser side c4 we've got pumping
priests going up against another
actually a very very exciting match as
well and then on the other side of that
we've got zark going up against malik
but c4 i want to ask you are there any
players that you picked out to be your
surprise winners
here i'm going to be straight up i know
should be supposed to say everyone's got
a chance but
nago plays napa yes it could happen it
could happen to you you could get
sidemen out he could win neutral and he
could
just destroy you before you even know
what happened first or two format if you
ask me nappa thrives in this he loves
first two
but
all the players are really strong we see
them here there and everywhere
especially you know from us to
commentating a lot of eu events
definitely no strangers all of these
players here like you said
pretty pretty german stacked but doesn't
mean that uh
the two non-germans can't make it
through so it'll be interesting man i'm
uh i'm looking forward to it i'm
definitely looking forward to see if
anyone's a laptop to defend against
snapper that's that's what i want to
know
yeah it should be interesting
well before we get into the action guys
let's have a very quick rundown of the
dragon ball fighters world championships
and how it's going to break down if you
go to just the next slide coming up
we'll explain just how it's going to go
down so the dragon ball fighters world
championship is going to start as it is
now in september november it will be the
tenkaichi online challenges these are
events run by you guys and find out
namco which are going to be on the line
and uh the winners of that will move
forwards remember right now is the
master challenge i believe those will
only be on pspc but everything else will
be on pc and ps4 but next we have the
regional financiers
yeah regional finals being held in
december uh the qualifying players from
the ten catchy uh they'll we'll get some
more slides to give you some more
information but you get the points from
the tenkachi and then you go forward
into the regional finals
that's going to be a slobber knocker
because that's just going to be the
region's just battling out it's going to
be crazy
uh yeah there we go community
tournaments and obviously the bandai
namco entertainment master challenge
that's what we got right here for you
but if you're a teo definitely reach out
get your tournament as part of the
series there you go that's the uh the
point format
there's so many points on the line man
yeah i wanted to say the tenkaichi
online master challenge that's what's
run by bandai namco what we're doing
right now has so many points available
so these are going to be big big
tournaments to decide who is going to be
representing their region moving forward
but also the points are scaled to events
so if you are doing an event make sure
you get as many people to sign up so
your region can fight for as many points
as possible
yeah as long as you can get people that
can uh as you know what if your dog can
hold a hitbox get them tender don't
worry about it just get everyone you can
and uh get those big points uh like we
were saying earlier doug mentioned about
the platforms pc and ps4
that will be for the ten catchy i think
for the finals that's uh only ps4
offline yeah
so
yeah no matter the format get involved
in the online tournaments grab those
points and these are the area zones
so there's quite a few here one through
to 11. uh we are here with uh europe
four yes uh you've already said the uh
the countries that are in part this
sweden denmark germany and what was the
last one sorry norway norway that's the
one yeah so
we had some last week like dunk was
saying about in america so today we have
four and then tomorrow we've got some
more eu action but right now
you are here regional finals that's
gonna be uh i think it was december
right yes there's something that's gonna
be like all off
this is really important right
everything after the 10k effects will
all be offline stuff we're going to have
running through three weeks and be
europe then usa then japan
and the winners of those events will be
moving forward to the big final event
going forward but remember i want to
really
you know
really emphasize this is all offline
from here on out and then we'll get to
the regional finals where it'll be 12
players with the a invited i believe we
have the eight invited from europe all
ready and then we'll have the four
qualifiers from that region so i believe
four from all of america four from japan
for from europe and then other stuff
going on and just how it works the top
four of all of those players in the
regional final will move forward to
dragon ball fighters world championship
final which will also be offline c4 yes
can't wait offline action back very very
shortly but right now this is how it's
going to break down
four players from eu but obviously
representing from each part eu one two
three and four they'll go to the
regionals and then the top four go
us split up into east and west two from
each side and then top four japan gets
top four as well uh from their uh
tenkachi going into the regionals and
top four and then mexico first place
australia first place brazil and mba
first place will go through
to
the world finals it's going to be
like the whole build up to this is like
a dragon ball episode
i couldn't do it i'm glad i'm behind the
camera not behind the stick
if you rto reach out there's going to be
a link in the chat that's going to be
dropped to get to the dragon ball f
z portal
for esports so you can sign up as a
player and i think you can get
information there as well if you want to
get your tournament down as a ten catchy
uh community event as well
yeah and make sure you do right even if
it's just the local that you run open it
up to everyone in that region and watch
them duke out it should be good fun i'm
excited to see you know what old faces
we see come forward but also what new
players we see emerge from all of these
regions and fly out offline but i
believe that's what we have in terms of
the run through
now c4 we get into the very juicy part
yes rub your hands because now we are
getting in to the action and i believe
the first game is going to be punder
going up against jonas but that should
be an interesting one for sure punder
we've definitely seen before we've seen
a lot of punder in terms of
online battle we've seen him and stuff
like one did i believe before we seen
him in cbks definitely a very strong
player i'm not sure what team they're
playing now we'll see wow okay this this
team is definitely very different to
what they were playing before um but
yeah
slightly uh
cooler
yeah yeah
interesting interesting i mean i've
always said like carrots and tail
normals
they've got stuff they've got that
they've got the classic id m you can't
uh that's always going to be strong this
one's going to be strong uh but jonas
i've seen yomas they've uh entered uh my
tournaments the cvk is to get to wedding
i don't know if they've got to want it
unfortunately but it's it's the trenches
bad in cbk's man like you've got to
prove yourself for five man round robin
but uh as you can see
jiren
and 21 with the point kid boo apparently
that's the favorite right now with both
plays uh rocking that uh something we
don't see too often both for the c
assist as well uh
yeah i think the team is a pretty evil
obviously by the kid but being the same
uh i think 21 and cooler kind of played
the same sort of mutual game they've got
a lot of like strong lows that go far
obviously got a whole ground uh and then
nothing to say about the geo we all know
what fujio though you all know what jio
does i was gonna say that vegeta for me
is gonna be the character to watch right
we've seen the assist be fantastic not
only for neutral not only for oppression
on offense but it's also a great
defensive assist we've seen that put to
great use in other regions i'm not going
to say france they don't need any
representation here but we've seen that
puts a great use in other regions and i
think that's a very important assist for
this matchup you're gonna see i think
punder play more around that neutral
game with these two sort of defensive
assists and then we're gonna see jonas
really just try and get in with that
kippu and
just mix wonder as much as he can i
think that's gonna be the name of the
game and as soon as the players already
will get into it but while we wait for
that guys i want to know who you're
excited to see in this bracket i'm sure
there's a lot of german fans in here
and you you are gonna have a treat
there's gonna be a lot of german team
kills and they're gonna be setting each
other out left right and center but if
you are a a
denmark or sweden player slash fan
you're definitely for your your two sole
representatives in poke cake alexia
yeah it's
you know it's just how tournaments go
it's unfortunate they're gonna have to
knock each other out
well not one of them into losers because
they are both winners to be fair uh you
hate to see it but it's the nature of
the beast man you gotta be good
you can't have friends when you're at
the top man there's no space up there
absolutely the podium's very small
and i was gonna say i want to have a
quick look at
the smashy g just to see who they be out
i believe
um jonas was beaten before earlier today
by someone else in topi or might be the
other way around um so panda actually
beat out mitch and zak and pumping
priests two other people we're gonna see
in the top eight okay to get to top
eight uh yona has actually beat hyali
and nago to get to top eight so it
should be a very interesting about both
players are ready to go and like you
said it's kid one point for both of them
it's gonna be
buttons thrown out at will uh we're
gonna see them throwing out really long
limb normals maybe try and use those two
and three ab normally try and catch
people off guard
right into the action sequence
yeah we can see punders pay in a very
like passive aggressive style right just
waiting for the uh the rope to come out
but jonas has got the corner with the
mix but no assist what this [ __ ] didn't
win any of it oh
this is gonna pay off oh no
that actually went for the reason that's
very cheeky didn't won the first game
with the big stage on top eight and
actually
oh i was gonna say michael's cash out
and get some damage on but that's his
[ __ ] done he's brought a lot of meter
but it's jonah's turn and he runs up
with the tournament as far as offense
yeah you've got a lot of those dragon
rush behind the uh the plus frames right
from the assist utilizing it very well
all right we're going to the shop where
we get him i don't know what that's
called that's like banana and kiwis and
stuff it looks yummy probably
too sweet yeah
we'll call it cake salad that will tell
us i'm going to call it a cake center
from now on but
there's no kicks in the sky getting the
dragon rush not enough to have to kill
we're going to get a pretty good setup i
believe jk i'm just joking guys it's all
good back to neutral
oh no he's going with the low no confirm
look under trying to go on the offense
but he should think about getting this
kid out he has seven meters so anything
gets hit out but he wants
three hands to move forward and the jm
connects mid air seven meters yeah you
have to drop some of that far don't be
cheap on that first date am i going to
see the geo level 3. how are we going to
see a vanishing figure we've seen that a
lot from the geo players no it's one for
long jump jm and that's the spot from
jonas
yeah now the weather the storm which is
called sparkling can he do it
gets clipped
it's the block though the air to air no
goods
oh
you know what at least it's not spike
damage we take those
i was gonna say what will reflect on
that cooler assist to actually get a hit
but no confirm afterwards you see
united's use that still to try and stop
plunders forward momentum but still he
comes forward and that five l will
connect and barring a drop it should
definitely be a kill even though for the
reject i was going to say keep it simple
and now put the you might regret that
yolanda is going to get three down a
free kill off this right jonah should
have lost this 21. absolutely but
instead the tables have been turned on
it's going to spend what two bar
right now three bar doesn't even matter
three well for the kill you have to take
it that's a that's a special offer for
sure
coming in with the uh
the spin in this the dolphin man himself
during his in the building try to put
his hand up stop sign but kid who says
you can't stop me i'm evil incarnate
what can you do oh we can press a two oh
that's got m scaling that's what we can
do all right don't check that
really threatening with that he really
wants to hit but nice jump back just
it's gonna be blue but like you say c4
if it's blue it's true
comes out
no it dies two all connects but that
could have been big damage but they're
very lucky
yeah pretty hard to confirm off the edge
wow the two
l reaches goes for the side swap don't
think it's gonna matter because i think
this durian
is going to survive the combo as
intended i know it's all right now gets
to go back to neutral maybe a bit of
zoning
this could be very bad no cooler gets
out of there could have been a horrible
situation but jonas foreign
i liked the fact that he went to give
you actually save some of the blue like
on jiren like i said don't be cheap on
that first date don't be cheap on that
first game and you're not looking to
seize it one character left
yeah there could be a bit of tournament
nerves you know being the first game on
stream all these people watching could
be making you feel the type of way but
the tail normal cross up this is how you
make a comeback hula a bag of meter
this should definitely be good right
he's gonna vanish and go for the level
one and c4 one thing i want to draw
attention to actually all of these
characters left are within one touch
range they will die in one hit so this
is definitely not out of the bag for
pogba he could get any hit oh what a
saiyan combined grab form uranus
under mid-air he's not gonna build that
third bar but sliding it down after the
grab you can see him trying to play that
mute again but
himself right next to the supernatural
the six h what are you stomping what are
you stomping that that five m went
astray
not gonna get three bars made nah i'm
not gonna get three bars right
look at the skills he has he has the
aliens could teleport behind him at any
time
so carefully
trying to snitch during assist good
block
oh snitching again tattletail i'm
grasping on you that's dead
please go straight into level three and
i love that go straight to level three
give yourself a chance it has gone down
to last characters for both of these
guys you can see the nerves creeping in
but to take this first game would surely
settle them it's cooler versus jiren to
end this one out jonas just backs up but
he gets this mother gm and that should
be enough to kill c4
[Music]
the great 1v3 comeback throwing the sun
at everyone everyone's catching novas
today
everyone all the aliens
cooler comebacks and this is the
character we was like hell i don't
understand but now i know i've got the
knowledge now i'm looking like cell
brother i understand why you got cooler
is this the
character than people kind of sleep on
to a degree right there was some players
in like all the seasons there was one or
two players that were like cool is not
that bad uh and i think people just
forgot but yeah boolah the older brother
in the building
taking names and getting a win for punta
[Music]
but good
awareness now he gets himself in the
corner and jonas spots up immediately
we're seeing sparks full stop very
quickly from both these things
here we go spark pressure early spark
again like you said but on this time
jonas
oh dragon rush yes reflect
no bueno
oh no
oh he tried to sneak out from the corner
but jiren
came up from his behind
i don't know if this can be enough to
kill he's gonna go level one level three
for sure
oh no he's offering to spend the level
ones and he gets like a month downstairs
and the jh will be enough i don't know
it wasn't a cow here so he didn't put
him up so he must have got him
absolutely raw jonathan takes the lead
but it costs his sparking and ponder
wants that back
he does oh i like it bringing it for geo
so a little bit from the last game so
you can get a bit more above the damage
output is there
[Music]
nice
spin the ball
surely you have to level three here and
someone do uh super chopped jm last time
just runs up this time based on the
reflect but the dr is not fast enough
jonas gets the whole tank out and you
can see jiren he was dead to whites he's
going to recover now
indeed all the ibm whips completely even
on vegeta with a very strong posture
he's standing very tall and it didn't
reach you know what does reach see
assist always get the knock down but no
confirm unfortunate for jonas dp
defensive assist here we go get the pie
slide probably throw him back in the
corner potentially let's find out if i'm
wrong all right i'm correct what you
saying
but next it has to be enough right
i'm lying it's not it's not a deal he
would have been enough to kill with that
torendo that was a
[Music]
don't give me this hype i told you about
tail normals
the hollywood stage i've seen why he's
here the third eye is open from
normal connected and quick confirm from
thunder
and still got two characters to work
through if he wants to advance js block
and that 2-0 would have been a ton of
damage but no
yeah we need to connect those man we
need to leave those into combos oh my
gosh give him the stance
he's positioned well
good posture oh what a
[Music]
illness has to make something happen
he's got the meter for it right if he
gets a hit surely he's spending me and
you can see him trying to go for that
yes
no fly zone right now for punto
yeah he's reaching
a little bit too far to get to jio
doesn't have to put
managed to get the confirm that's
one-on-one rokunda has that sparking in
the back of his pocket he's also got
seven minutes to spend and cooler with
me
not a nice sightseeing did you see that
i saw looking for it was it was an aqua
color but the damage is still real oh
captain dash
okay here we go don't drop it
oh he's keeping it super simple kiss
keep it simple silly let's go
he looks a little bit at the end of the
dash but with that level three
window it's gonna supernova his way
forward
until winners
when his finals yeah we're just trying
to i'll think about it for a second
there a bit confused how tournaments
work but yeah he's gonna go straight
forward so winners finally jonas gonna
drop
in to the losers bracket
again man cooler i think was the biggest
difference right uh again it could be
something to do with like unfamiliarity
because you don't come across a lot of
them yeah uh what's the cap strong we'll
never know we'll have to find out i mean
if one wins the whole world tour i'm
sure this will start changing but right
now
uh you can't deny how much work cooler
did and
it's really interesting because when you
look at matches you can go okay maybe he
could have done that with another
character i think cool has got
very
he's got a lot of tools that only he can
do he's got the shockwave that's a low
only he has that no one's got anything
close to that his 3h is pretty unique as
well being able to go through beams
i think he's like and a lot of people
talk about uh air dp's being the thing
he's got that so
bunda going through like he said into
winners finals 2-0 over his brother
jonas send him into losers gonna have to
duke out with some more germans down
there
it will be interesting to see if he can
pull it back because i don't think jonas
felt like they were very like patient
uh and waiting for like the big hits but
i had a couple of drops and like we said
it might be tournament nerves big stage
a lot of people watching so much at
stake even though it's free tonight so
get on that but there's so much at stake
it it could dawn in you when you go on
the top eight
oh i mean top eight okay
and that can do a lot to you like
mentally answer your hands man i've i've
been in that situation your hand just go
to jelly when you know you're so close
to the end it's like when you have when
you know you have so many eyes on you
and you know it's such a big game uh it
can be quite daunting and i think jonas
felt that a little bit there but punder
will be moving forwards
i see people in the chat by the way you
guys are saying that we should address
him by his actual name lord cooler
apologies won't happen again um but i
think we're getting ready for our next
game and this is going to be quite sad
as well if you are not a german player
right it's phone cake going up against
alexia poncake representing denmark well
fighting out of denmark originally from
kuwaiti and then alexiad
who is going to be representing sweden
actually just spoke to me but anyway
alex said gonna be playing as sweden
yeah no don't worry about it alexander
gonna be playing for sweden i believe
alexa plays 18 and we're actually going
to get right into the games i'm very
excited for this
oh shout outs to production i see the
flags i respect it
uh
oh i unrespected
by this is it it's correct now because
that's where they're playing from jazz
to croatia but punk can't get a very
strong adult gold hand player
and another point can boo
the vanilla variety as well gotta love
it
[Music]
very excited clx we've seen alexa in a
series known as wanted and they've
fallen
every time but they're very very strong
and this is their chance this is their
sort of tries to break out into the
scene very excited see other people okay
goes on the offensive
and i wonder how are we gonna see
someone invest into that level seven
gohan we've seen a lot of people do
actually
i mean black characters are threat i've
seen a couple of people put them last
and i was like i don't go on last if you
get the levels
i think they're very
capable anchor uh but right now
i mean pooncake hasn't got enough bars
and he's close to being on his anchor as
alex does get rid of uh playing
character another thing about them is
that uh they're 18 they've been on the
18 train from day they never got off the
train they're still waiting for the stop
the travel card is is expired but
they're they're still making it happen
let's see
fresh with ui
yeah ui versus ui pressure is scary
because at any moment both of them could
bust out and that's exactly what alexia
sorry that's exactly what poke tried to
do alexia had that barrier ready and
waited barrier qualifying that here and
alexa just looking to go on the
offensive i love that ux using ex
it's getting confirmed fast forward
spots up has to go out
[Music]
this character is so good
just
she is like the opinion of denial like i
know you think it's okay because you're
you are but no just just no
oh two agents of spark wow you really
don't like that'll go on okay so the
spark was actually to keep it safe have
you seen a change from your goku where
it's easier to punish this ph alexa knew
that sparked up and said okay cool i'm
not trying to hold anything after we'll
get the kill now it's all locked to the
skull it's all up to don't go happy he's
got seven meters right so if he does get
hit we could see him level up
all of his team
completely hold it's gonna be
it is and this is not how you start one
right ui goku getting a hit brings it oh
yeah yeah it's time to be here oh my
brother and me
i can't see that's what that means it's
called just made up
hit by the
no the legs too strong those seven bars
aren't going to get spent if you can't
get to the shop you need to hit
hit your mark
and cash out
bothering me i can't see
unlock the patience from home yes
and he'll be rewarded with his own hit
he said that he's because of the break
but what are you gonna do level three or
level up and we're gonna see the level
one doesn't have to spend any more meter
interesting oh
i mean
probably spending all that bar wouldn't
have helped this situation right there's
not much else
we could have done in that situation
it's a pretty sticky
scenario that uh on cake found himself
in but uh
if you are gonna like you have to level
through there and if you're not gonna
level three up there
you spend all the meat on the level
because you do not know when you're
gonna get another hit right that was one
touchy situation for home right that
gohan was gonna die in one hit you have
to cash out everything you have i think
it's a bit of a mistake from punk cake
well alexander will take it he took that
game relatively oh sorry they took again
red relatively
see if they can
take the win here but that guess reflect
we'll be punished by 2m
they're going to see the staircase oh we
don't do elevator we don't take
elevators yeah that's what i'd like to
see
safe jump into a barrier
yeah so that's actually the change
because it's not like real dp
quote-unquote anymore you can call
assist during it alexander try to take
advantage but that 2m will connect it's
going to be more than enough damage
for poke to get this kill and i'd love
to keep it real simple level one if you
love one shooting more than enough it
doesn't
man it's uh it's been a long time since
i've seen uh kick boo too touch on one
nice
that's pretty right i like that all
reach and grab
special five l into
guess the r guess come on grab oh and
that's the guess for a flight coming out
from pokemon could have got more
obstacles that was like a pretty
long
mix-up and now the respect from homecake
he actually dropped him will spark up
because
connects with that to our alexia
it's gonna have to weather out this
parkinson's
this might be another two such oh not
bringing in the
scholar oh air
jason oh my gosh there's slickness
doesn't go for all the loot just wants
to keep it simple and doesn't even have
to spend any meter home cake takes the
lead in terms of characters it costs
[ __ ] alexa 20
in the game right um what has that 21
has that sparking the right now poking
going on the offense we're gonna see him
go into level three spend it all
and alex said are you to spark up here
why are you going to try and block it
out
tries to book it out and get the odds of
his troubles and that should be enough
home case
should have enough to get the kill
there's the level one another one from
goku and the kid who should have
finished off we're going into game three
alexia saving his sparky for some other
game he's not gonna get to music here
we're gonna go for game three
yeah i mean that that situation there's
two types of people in the world there's
people that spark on wake up regardless
and people that wait to block in their
spark
we know
you know who
one of them is they definitely were
waiting for some blocks done the blocks
never came because the doctor came
instead mr dr himself
completely just said yeah there's
resources that you everyone has at the
start of the game you're just not gonna
get to use it right now you're gonna
have to utilize your left and right what
a good block on the cross up yep oh but
what a great two hd4 from alexa won't
get much damage obviously in 18 are we
gonna set up my brother and me no
reflect this time and that means you
have to spawn that makes up is so scary
if you don't play
yeah now oh my gosh auto block god bless
you okay okay yeah yeah you're cute and
you're human no
because that first block was looking mad
crazy quick
lift them up again
all right pass through 18 let's go
yeah that's pretty far here are you
going to spend it no
my brother and me mix-ups
i think he's gonna go for level three
here
no set up my brother
takes
[Music]
to jab in the super dash raw tag working
out
zoom tight
blocks those things again
oh great block again
and here comes poke forces the sparky
from alexa but now you have to fight out
of
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not six in the morning it's night
time why are you stretching and boy is
that a wake-up call because your head
down and did you see how long pokey is
waiting he's waiting for all of that to
be done a lot of people make that
mistake right they fight that too early
okay not this time and he's gonna leave
in in the final game in a sec
i i love droppings like that dumpings
like that always always make me real
back
what that was
it was sick you know what the intent
made it look really good like that
looked like an actual converter even
though it's definitely not the intent
was there we're eating cupcakes
yuck right left right though
it's a low and it's a good block from
volcano the command comes sticking
afterwards
no couple after has no meter for ex
don't get a dog gohan out there you can
see punky threatening with that m low
but great confirmation
i want to know what he spent okay level
three i like it slow down the pace of
the game and start convicted right he's
got one mix after the level three he's
also got uh team gohan he's on the dope
behind us afterwards to work with it but
great to have from okay to stop that raw
tag and it is all up to android 21 to
bring it on
room cake is ready ready the
bibliotheque the bibliotheque the
library read it saw the broadside coming
a mile away but
can you see where the mix-up's gonna be
oh no no no i haven't got enough for
level three but with the potent normals
don't get crab good jump out there some
phone cake reflected away no kind of
tries to use the jm interrupted
you can see how patiently pancake wants
to play not just not forcing
[Music]
but he will go for that level three and
it's good for your life right it could
be anything there's gotta be a back fist
in the future absolutely
that'll do it no five no great tech
back to neutral i love this from pancake
don't even want to go forward play
patiently but the command will connect
obstacle for the ex
[Music]
i don't think try to get one but
by staying there
that you were talking about and punk
cake
will end up taking it with a reverse
sweep over alexian
okay we'll go forwards
to win this final what play
yeah fully well played uh i'm just
thinking about my career what's the
point of commenting if i'm just gonna
play spoilers i just knew what's gonna
happen but uh yeah i'll let you do most
of the commentary because i'm just going
to ruin it for everyone else i've
clearly seen what's going to happen so
we should just add a spoiler tag to you
you know too much but that that's great
c4's third eye is open that means we get
to see
all of the action
from his perspective but alex said we'll
go down into loser's bracket and you
have to fight the shark tank that is the
german players down there um and that's
a little bit horrifying uh but alexa
definitely a very very strong player
that's our winner's final setup though
it's going to be punder going up against
pumpkin that should be a very
interesting fight between them but next
up we actually have pumping priest going
up against nago and i know you're a big
fan of naga
i am i've been big fan and i go uh
they've i've seen them play a lot uh
to stuff on my stream
i think it's something all nappa players
do and once they commit to napa the
other two characters is interchangeable
and i've seen nago just develop like
okay i think this is the strongest way
to make uh
napa like optimal and stuff like that so
i want to see what they've settled with
because when it comes to obviously dbz
world championship
you have to go with what you think is
the strongest like you're going to go
with the half
hearted stuff right you're going to go
to i need to win these two games as
quick as possible so my opponent doesn't
get any downloads on me especially
losers you can't afford to
to you know do something you're not
comfortable so i'm really interested to
see what they bring to the table and
if anyone comes up with a good answer
against it other than spark that's the
answer i always pick it's the best one
but you only can do it once so and what
i was gonna say is you're worried about
the nappa on offense when he's got you
locked down and he's performing mix on
me i'm worried about napa in neutral
because if he plants that side man boy
is that a pain to get rid of remember
the change this season
it doesn't care about projectiles
anymore right and that's how a lot of
people got around plants in neutral
it'll just throw a projectile get rid of
it now you have to be very very wary and
i'm wondering if pumpkin priest has what
it takes i'm wondering what team pumping
priest does play because i actually
don't know much about them but it
doesn't really matter when you're going
up against stepper um
it really is a race right it becomes a
race to kill nappa because once you get
rid of nappa i think
generally those teams kind of fall apart
because usually they are all supporting
members for that napa team so if pumping
priest does have a team um that is maybe
a bit faster i'm looking at it now
actually
it is quite a fast-paced team right
you've got that tone who can really
answer the napa well but i'm looking at
nago's team
that is very horrifying um you've got
vegeta one of the
newly found top tiers i'll call him he's
very very strong very good changes to
make them strong um and basically cool i
think base goku is a fantastic anchor to
have in the back right uh when you get
access to that that level seven
character it's a lot of damage but also
has a excellent access to opening you up
right with the 5.0 tick though i'm
taking all the 5l dr there's a lot of
a lot of pressure there on that team and
i think that i think nago's gonna find
it very easy uh in terms of neutral with
the veggieo and then once he wins
neutral it's like okay i'm gonna bring a
nappa and then start planting with me so
pumping breeze has to be super ready for
that
yeah i think it's always interesting
when two point characters don't have a
beam
and that's what we have in these two
because normally we have a beam that's
like i can call out your s's with a beam
right that's like the the sort of like
rock paper scissors situation you have
but both of these players don't have a
beam both the point characters sorry
total hunt of a geo
i think at one point fajita was just the
worst tolhan
he's not like i don't think he's like
that anymore because they used to do mad
damage but tolhan had legs he had leg
mitts and yes vegeta didn't really have
anything uh times have changed 2021
shout outs we're here now
mr nomics is
mr no mix that hits
that's that's all he is same side sword
sss
sexy super stylish that could happen
i'm gonna say should we count the ssss
we get right we have to swear by the
society somewhere but the sss is super
strong right a lot of people think to
themselves yeah i'm not going to get
opened up my same side sword it is a
very tough
well we are going to see if now players
gonna get into lobby i was gonna say
though pumping priest's team i think is
very centered around the
sort of neutral game of playing slowly
with that team go home but once you do
get that once you do lock them down it's
very fast paced right team gohan has
very good startup saga bands right that
m being minus three is very scary it's a
very good it's when you see a lot of
team players sort of restart their
pressure they'll do like five l dr
shouts here to rock it somewhere um but
he's that five ldr is a very good
stagger string and then you have the
cross up jl in your arsenal as well
tingohan is very very scary to block if
you choose to um and i'm gonna emphasize
true
because if i'm a vegito player i refuse
to because i have access to 214s so
that's a great call-out tool on someone
that's going to stagger one and i i hope
to see um nego use it
yeah i think that's definitely a tool
that we don't really see on defense too
much i mean 16 one's a lot better it's
quicker because and it's got it's got
like a pseudo strike on it that's
insanely fast so you always have like a
kind of coverage uh but like you said i
think that's a good option even for
gto's i've started to see people use uh
progetto's 2h literally like a flash
kick i know it looks like a somersault
but
they're using it in any gap they're
going i'm just going to do this like
let's see what happens and it works a
lot because it actually does hit even if
he's not facing him so if you cross him
up and he's doing the flash keep the
other way you still get clipped and when
you get clipped by 2h it's all the same
you're going to hit animation taking to
the skies you're going to lose 50
percent let's see if that's going to be
a factor wow that for gl color is i feel
like i've never seen it before i must
have
this is complete deletion i'm the
perfect one
like like jagermeigh bro just write the
name of the death note oh my gosh
orchestra
[Applause]
it's not even close
it's instead with extra damage
yeah like you said that was dead with a
side of chips and some bits but that was
uh
was that intentional i hope it was
wow
pumping priest is
pumping on the acceleration he's going a
mile an hour brother nago has not got a
chance to get out of this corner
you get out of the corner when i want to
make sure you all notice him he must
have won the 5m there surely
he tried to come on grabbing he's
actually going to
put himself in the corner with that
come out from that they will reflect to
get out of that situation but while
we're seeing that baby [ __ ] breathing
h very irregular i'd say for a mapper
player
by the way i want to mention that
you might be getting a serving let's see
maybe
trying to keep some space
oh
perfect one that's a winning that was
fun
i'm gonna say look
they say it's never overt
it's not over until
oh
i was gonna say the fat lady starts
singing but boy is she not ready to see
she's doing that oh my goodness you're
thinking she's whispering my ears i can
hear in production
i'm still alive it's okay good afternoon
michael with the basically
you like you say the fat lady's singing
but right now we don't even know who we
don't know who's gonna end up taking it
i am so surprised that high voltage was
actually negative but another was like
now i'm pressing button right here right
now
oh no
back to the corner you go sir what a
block on that crosstalk
oh my gosh she's being mad
getting it done
that's all we can say about that game
and boy honestly the first set of games
between alexander um
alexander and
kunda earlier it was kind of slow
measured pace and these two were coming
out swinging from they're coming out
fists up okay let's go we're swinging
round one and pumpkin priest will end up
taking that and i feel finagle
take a second take a break relax because
if you play to pump increase speed if
you play to his pace you're doing
everything he wants to i i really feel
like nago has to play towards that game
kind of get hit get that nap in and
really really hold down pumpkin grease
we're going to get right into the second
game
one game away from moving forward
getting away from being eliminated whoa
i was about to say that is not how you
want to start your match in two ended by
tolhan oh sword time in the corner
you're one hit
yeah you know what i agree with that
spot because pamper knows if i get hit
again nap is coming in and it might be a
gg shake my hand thank you for the games
send me your details
you can play later
in the rain
i can't see good neither could you spark
oh
i know it's top eight
we're playing for a lot here
this is your guy this is your character
[Music]
that goes young by the way people in the
chat like he's very young and so
yeah
like that bounce back
oh
let's go
and we're going to see again here comes
the plant you've been red before
will you be red again
over here one
not on your main guys don't do it on
your main don't get points
oh no
is there a point cyberman
[Music]
have you ever have you ever been so
impressed by simon that you just did
level one
no okay so that's new right
so
that's
what
sense why he did it but nigel was just
standing there looking like i'm not
doing offenses
you forgot i'm seated i'm napping i'm
seated it's the cyberman that's s here
because we do stuff like that
independent pouring it like this i've
been moving like beyonce
and look that vanish it's not your turn
you might think it's your turn right
here comes beyonce
i'm independent i'll do what i want
you can't stop me
the sideman is always on time that's
your facebook that's the new neighbor
sasha fierce you can't even do comp you
can't do blockchains you can't do combos
on the ground you just can't be there
this is this is lovely right you have to
be ready for the sideman to interrupt
you and a lot of players choose to do
things like supernatural dr to stop it
and pumping priest is gonna have to
adapt right now you don't get another
chance you're a loser you lose this one
you're out
oh
and somebody
rightfully said now we have a match
you're absolutely right because napoleon
has come out to play a boy
this is what we're saying from the first
game right like naga just didn't get the
napa train started and it's a very
top-heavy team but we've seen how
effective it is it's like yeah okay i
didn't get the first one for geo my team
kona goes downhill because i don't get
the napa like gameplay started
they got one hit
and pump
sparked
just from the first hit because he knew
what was going to happen next he's like
if i get here again i'm going to have to
watch this guy
like just plant in front of me he's
going to be green fingers in front of me
just
put pulling pulling potatoes out of
ground i don't want to get hit by the
potatoes
yeah cause you can't do nothing about it
you can see him plot vanish and go oh
and now i'm in a sandwich subways
brother i don't want to be between napa
and this st character the s doesn't
stand for what the name of the thing is
it's just st
he plucks it right and everyone thinks
he's playing a side note i've got news
for you he's quite neutral
he's playing neutral
it's a it's a swiss army knife right he
plants a swiss army army knife puts it
down looks to you says okay you'll move
it's rough it is so scary but you have
to adapt right and we've seen i'm going
to show a player from an offline that we
we were both at we both commented has
right we've seen taz tackle plugs nappa
right and he was using the fast buttons
that cell had to sort of knock the
sideman out make sure that he didn't get
any sort of pressure started we're gonna
have to see something like that from
pumpkin please otherwise not go nacro
players once they smell blood that's it
they're on it they see your weakness
they will exploit this they will
continue to fight you in in their
favorable position right and i think
we're gonna see uh we're gonna see nago
continue to go into that world right try
and get one hit go straight to napa and
because of the way meter works in this
game you're more than guaranteed to have
one bar after you hit somebody right so
that means he's going to get the ex um
ex not down he's going to get the plant
and from there
yes
it's crazy so
yeah like i think most napa players i
always see as it's kind of a troll but
it's not
when something goes bad for a napper
player their strategy is get fertilizer
we just need more plant we need to we
need to plot more assignments
that's normally what happened but
unfortunately
spectators
were they clearly got hit by simon
because
they they kind of scuffed up their job
they couldn't watch they said damn i saw
pamper get hit from behind by suddenly
let me watch my back
then we're paying attention to the
screen unfortunately so uh we are going
to miss this last match
match but like as i said it happens um
yeah but for now
right we don't want to pull them out
this is an important match like the
adrenaline is probably pumping for both
players so yeah we can't really pull
them out so
i actually want to draw attention to
something you said earlier right about
[ __ ] is definitely a young player i'm
not sure they're exactly but they're
they're younger than mr popo right which
is
one of these traditional players right
almost
he's barely spawned in right like but
he's very young um
and i'm wondering because this is
probably his first experience being in a
topic right
can you keep those nerves under control
um because i i've never been lucky
enough to be in the top 84 have you been
in top 8 where you've sort of had nerves
knocking on the door uh
not topic i've been first that's what
traffic says
it's definitely like nerve-racking for
sure
i don't think it really matters if it's
online or offline uh
it's always the stakes the states can
always make you think like maybe
normally i beat this character or you're
versus your friend and you're like yeah
i normally you know i normally watch
them wherever but when it's first or two
and it matters and there's like money on
the line or trophies or for me just ego
it changes everything it changes
completely everything so i can't imagine
doing it that young though i couldn't i
can do it i'll crumble
at the
at the prospect of like being on such a
big stage
with so little like uh tournament
experience
and and the thing is right it's
online now but it's good training for
we're gonna have in the future right
because after the online 10k events from
now on out it's offline right and you
have to deal with some of the biggest i
will call eagles i'm gonna call them
egos in dragon ball fighters right we
have
eight players invited in europe already
and you're looking at that list those
players are super strong so you're not
only gonna have to tackle all of these
online players and have that ego to
surpass them you're also gonna have to
pass these stronger players off a line
players are still in the match um
we're gonna imagine that nago is doing
amazing cyberman makes or pumping priest
is hitting him with cross-up cell um
rolling crush yeah that was sick
ah okay so we got the results should we
tell them straight away oh no the uh
jazz the production
spoilers in the chat there you go that's
who won pumping priest does pull it out
and we've seen that the the matchup is
very
i don't want to say volatile but very
like landslide right
the momentum and everyone says like oh
yeah the person who gets the first two
wins
in this matchup it felt very much that
was the key thing to do you get the
first hit because they both sparked
after the first hit regardless of the
damage or what assists were on deck
they know that the momentum is so key
in beating the other opponent and yeah
today
in the first of two pompo got the two
yep
and i'll be moving forward that's going
to be all we're going to be seeing from
nago in terms of today
that means we set up one of our
quarterfinals alex said gonna be playing
a pumping priest
should be a fantastic match but now we
set up our next one
right this is going to be zak going up
against malik
another german tinker right one of these
plays is going to be going home
and like you said the stakes are high
this is the 10k masters of it there is a
lot of points on the line i believe 200
points on the line for first
indeed so winning this you put yourself
in a great position to be number one
like all the tournaments that are going
to be getting you points are going to be
important
getting 200 points when the max you can
get from the other events is 100
i don't need to explain match to people
that's a big deal
that's a big big deal so like you said
there's a lot to play for here this is
very important for the players that got
the top eight because i know it wasn't
an easy tournament to even get to top
eighteen right and
when you're when you're back's against
the walkers you're in losers and it's
like i can't afford to lose right it's
it's scary down there man it's scary
like you said it's a it's a shark tank
uh and they're all bleeding shots so
they can smell each other's blood like
yeah you might not go for this because
it's super risky and you don't want to
get knocked out so uh it's it's hard man
so
these teams though
yeah i was gonna comment on this right
so i actually had a conversation with
wade a while back right and we were
talking about how kefla and two
defensive assists is some of the the
best stuff in the game some of the best
team synergy in the game and that's what
we're gonna see on one side in terms of
malik's team right it's kefla with ui
goku assist with the geoisis that's a
great great team but on the other side
you've got zogs not playing blue goku a
character i think not many characters
not many people have sort of
fully developed in their minds but it's
very very strong backed by that vegeta
backed by that 21. i'm very excited to
see how both these guys play out
i'm super interested into why the
maskers doesn't have the geo or anything
i mean damascus doesn't want to win
cleanly
messing up the mojo i mean he's got
jennifer he's kind of swaying it's kind
of sweet but yeah like
something that's you know
kind of a wave of like vegeta blues
coming
why not c4
[Music]
he's got no mix he hits you with same
side stuff all the time it looks really
interesting like
i don't know
i don't have to win but these players do
it doesn't mean it's going to be going
out of it manic versus up going on right
now and so
we'll get that guys here take
it
[Music]
he's a character that has nothing but
does everything that's the best way to
shape the geo he does my damage though
as you're gonna see from his level three
should be enough lies
but look at the spacing here from zach
right and he's like yeah
if you want to
approach goes in brings in uh flex take
him out the corner though what the
pressure of ui is kind of putting
anywhere right doc yeah you've got the
super jumper with jm if you wanted to
physics and loads of options and we
actually saw it super dash is off the
command situation and you saw malik tech
there i'm gonna i'm gonna let you in on
the sequel right
very good players see the flash of ex
moves and figures there and that's
exactly what zark tried to do there it
did work out for malik because right
back from your offensive
are you gonna have enough to kill sir
i'm surprised he was allowed to explain
the illuminati take i think mum was the
worst i don't know how you now all the
top players are going to lose
like now you know not enough to beat him
literally cooler jump s i don't know how
you got away with that but
uh silence
[Music]
so the quarter position
probably gonna have to give up unless
they want to spend the bar let's see
they can see that that's one of the
things
on the offensive oh my goodness they
tried some
some devilish check right now
yo one inch punch i i i wanted to do it
again i i i like that technology
i'm all about the swords look at that
movement
[Music]
i'm so tired you get another 10 seconds
on the bike though you go
that was all i had
his life was all blocked
out of here
[Music]
he got 12 bumps out of here kefla
bringing it back and carefully was
literally on death's door right at the
beginning of this match right and
yes
like 360 notes go
it was slightly neat though didn't get
the smash after the vanish you can see
how patient zombies looking for one
opportunity goes to the common ground
nice job out from malik will get the
kepler out of there now you have to deal
with the sassy man himself
indeed what blocking the cross up
malik is ready
and willing
to go in approaching slowly
esports kicks big whiff trying to slice
them out of the sky
no dice fingers keep some pin down and
here we go
[Music]
super sexy stylish
let's see the damage oh you go
insane amounts of bar here
well this is for good reason right spend
all of that meter you cut a little bit
of blue light from zark and now the
sparking is
less potent we know zach is going to
spark him because he has it
really because he asked me
because
i love you my crystal ball i'll nudge
you my christopher there you go there
you go you don't take he's spark instead
oh
though from this way
he's trying to do it there you go
right after he actually slid behind
because the momentum of the energy boom
that's the right one this is something
very good
100
go get through this kepler
weighing out the patience and the
challenge brac hits
take your turn sir take your turn backs
up brings it back one character piece
[ __ ] will fade
[Music]
yeah i think i can hear the buffering oh
vanish
a little bit too late didn't get to
confirm yeah all the way from germany
though
another connection but this that
connection failed and actually zonk
takes back the momentum i actually think
with the vanish combo he should have
enough to kill and he will go straight
into level three
and that's gonna be making more comeback
really nice really good patience really
good composure and that's exactly
exactly what you need if you want to run
it back
and again we've seen another 1v3
comeback the the composure was just
there and i think this happens a lot in
in dragon ball especially when the first
couple of uh exchanges in the game are
like hectic and when you know you can't
take risk because you're on your last
character people seem to be really sick
at fighting games right they're like
spacing's on point they're blocking like
it's crazy right they're not just
matching super dax because it's like
damn if this goes wrong i've got nothing
to fall back on
yeah everyone goes oh right okay so the
whole idea is not to get here as as well
as hit the opponent okay i think i can
do that and then you get two assist
again and
then you just worry about your script
but that was really good showing from
zarc uh 21 a very strong character but
utilize them
very very well against three pretty
strong characters i'd say kept is still
up there like she's not full enough
because she's got weak i think she fell
off because some other people caught up
all right
enjoy this knockdown
which keeps it simple try six seven good
blocks there and that's the trade on the
five volts after the success
yeah awareness situations have been
lagged corner has been established
kepler
going in on blue here
oh you're dead don't leave a message
he's not coming back
your message has not been received it's
gonna be blue goku going down malik
looking for vengeance
yeah
not probably happy about the comeback
right you never feel good when someone
comes back with one character and you've
got all that momentum and character
health
doesn't feel good but you don't want to
go too ham right because i think that
was the downfall i think
manic was so
so confident in the lead that they
couldn't lose and obviously they're lost
right so i'll be a little bit careful
don't
don't look at it as that you have to win
look at that you have to keep your life
lead but right now malik get the hero
for go
throw them back into the mid screen
gonna hit him with the swords and we're
gonna go munch
the g05
that's how this started
and i think it's gonna end with the 21
jh no try to go through our malik he
likes his powers
[Music]
he's going to spend as much
as they can and because this started in
sparky there is going to be no blue
light for that right so this if it
happens
a little bit of blue light left
yeah it's a shame because i think if
they would have got that reject that
would have been a dod
that's
the stuff that people already dream of
like three spots look at my combo tod
fire buy starter two assists ultimately
that's that big ball
oh thank you
you said that
definitely someone's going to clip it i
won't have to tell them too all right
and we saw this earlier right the left
right is potent let's see
we should not go to the low mallet
you've been ready good block
looking to bring this back to 1-1 but
all that stands between
again with a free one
it's not looking like me malik saying
fool me one shame on me
come back at me twice no bueno i
couldn't figure anything around with it
i'm not as good as dumb cat this i'm
sorry
that's a hard run
[Music]
no escape
because we have to be serious about this
vegeta fighter it is nine frames
that is less like that if you think
about how seconds work that's less than
a tenth of a second right it's also very
very big
yeah it's very big so i'm not even it's
a mid yes i understand it's a mid it
goes very far it's very fast you add all
of that together you get neutral and
that's exactly what he threw out there
and it worked vitamin is a great button
for video to use to sort of catch people
trying to run away it was used by malik
very well
but zach
you've got one up what both of you both
of you plays have one opportunity to
keep themselves alive in
nothing
who's going to end up taking it
dark or malec
badly
fun ones are i'm not doing good for my
blood levels man oh my gosh leave again
elbow to the grill protect your face
mids only guys mids only you win by
neutral not mixed
is it knocked down don't get wrapped oh
god
there we go
give him this give him the hands boom
i love the two i don't know why it might
be because i'm a boomer but i really
like uh the
the 2m frame kill with you i
don't know why oh i also like called an
assist defensively and get hit by a ki
blast not even a beat
i want you to recognize both of these
both of them did it to each other
they both did the same thing to each
other
[Music]
gonna have to pull out something special
before in that game
all the chips on the table
here we go
yeah look at the staggering pressure
[Music]
what do you
i'll say flats do and over again because
that's that's how you recognize yourself
in it right you get hit because i was
little cross you're plus again
you couldn't really do anything
you just have to make yourself feel
better
by going through the motions
you're in block city oh there's the
valley
that jayhead zark recognizes he's a bad
position wow
jh will connect no me uh
i love that keep the corner keep that
pressure on jh to look down we'll jump
back jm and there's vegeta when sparking
this is a horrible stereotype
hold me this horse
the salsa let's go you got seven bars
you've got a lot of people watching yeah
get down to one of us do the saucy stuff
get level three
maybe force the spark out here
t one's [ __ ] instead
for the special tech it's not punished
a sliver of help for that
will just be enough malik is gonna lose
his work
two characters against malik still has
that sparky
oh that was a very risky
split finger shot there oh we're in
there
we punish your bad neutral big five m
star aqua combos didn't want to sip up
don't hide dre hold this combo start
bringing it back again
[Music]
yes spend it span that level three
and this time malik has no sparky you
have to well i'm sorry had sparky
try to get out of the mix there there is
[Music]
it but it doesn't you still get the same
side swap regardless
oh my gosh punch the back chiropractor
in the building
malik
he's in the lead here looking like they
might close out they just need not
another chance you have available much
me up you have to spend the level three
and we're going to see something come
out right
it's going to be vanishing super jump i
don't know you have to make this count
there's the vanish five elf
i think malik was walking
i think that's it yeah don't
we made this counter even better because
the lack of mix
the lack of mix
come back zark never count them out
mlp
tso a lot of letters remember them all
they if you rearrange them it's an
anagram for i'm always in the winner
one character two counts of three i can
still win zark
that was oh my heart's racing
that that's what you need to do to be on
top of it right you have to be ready to
be clutch in those situations and
honestly it's heartbreaking once i put
like sheer jubilation on the other
that's going to be setting up our second
quarter final it's going to be jonas
going up against zarg malik dropping out
of the tournament
two ones mandate yeah we've had some
some nail buyers yep
now we're in the
top six
we're gonna keep cutting it down until
we find out who's your number one here
oh boy oh i'm still in shock cause that
is super clutch there from zark and i'm
sure zak is very um
very shook has to take a bit of time to
themselves i think we're not going to be
seeing those games at the moment we're
going to be going back up to win a side
if i'm correct
what
so we'll come down let's take a breath i
don't think we're going to see some
we get to see las vegas for a little bit
and for a little bit only for a little
bit yeah coming straight back into it
definitely backlog hardly i'll be back
what a great game these guys put on a
fantastic show for europe region 4 of
the 10k event i think
players are okay sorry next match is
actually going to be losers court final
i think we're gonna go back up to the
other side um so that should be
interesting for us and we're keeping
your high stakes right because once like
you said before we're talking about when
you're in loser's side it starts to get
really scary um every single decision
you make could be one step closer to
being
out at all and like we said this is
super high stakes loads of points on the
line for the 10kg online events you
really want to get your dubs in early
for sure for sure um
i think
it with dragon ball i feel like a lot of
the gameplay is like
get rid of your opponent as quick as
possible and that's kind of how you go
approach the whole tournament right
you don't zark is a perfect example of
why some people go
it doesn't matter about having the life
lead i need to get rid of them things
like limit break spark and meter and
characters like the geo yeah they
haven't got mixed you can just sit there
and block but the one time you try to
just move that's when they hit you and
that's when you regret every
every decision you made in the match
when it just came down to one right and
that's just getting hit by mid or just
not holding back because you're too
you're anticipating cross-ups and stuff
like that and uh
it's it's a minefield out there going
for the tournament at each match just
having to go against all these great
players that uh from your region as well
so they've probably played each other
right especially because most of the top
eight was from germany they're probably
like training partners at least right
yeah no i was gonna say like they
probably play a lot offline together
they'll probably have a community
together so it will be rough but these
guys not from the same country right
this is alexia going up against pumping
proofs we saw pumping priest dispatch
nago 2-1 earlier on alexander did go
down to poncake in the winner's side
looking to bounce back i believe the
players are just about ready to go and
we've seen these huge before right we
know exactly what alexia's going to be
about calling that barrier to sort of
bait you in sort of like a matador right
pull you in with that red
cloak right over your head but pumping
priests is all gas no breaks right in
they want to go
we'll see who ends up i think that's
actually what it's going to be right
it's the battle versus the ball that's
what this matchup is ready i i agree
yeah i think the celebration for pumping
priest look right in there oh but back's
away oh no didn't have any assists that
kind of makes sense you don't want to
really go in on your wife you've got
nothing to back that's kind of scary
good dragon rush
want to set the president that you're no
slouch you're gonna have to get kind of
creative oh and
whoa
what where footage of toronto are going
uh
straight right actually
here comes my brother and me
didn't need to see we've got spark on
deck but a 5m whips unfortunate
now tohan gets to do the the 5s game
oh never mind going gonna bring in the
arch nemesis itself nice
idea to confirm i didn't quite get it
nearly got me there oh my gosh my back
what's going to get from this
oh reset just
there was two in there as well that's
unfortunate didn't get the confirm
jumped away
yo
i love the way that
pumping priest can just clutter the
screen with plasma i love it
as the returning keyblocks on deck and
there is there's the other baby shower
coming out
they keep us just coming back it's
already on either side
alexia back against the wall
you see vanish yeah vanish to get
slightly knocked down
safe job you have to go safe
right
i was correct but alexa had
but like you said that's kind of the
nature of uh alex's team this you might
have the right answer but it's not
always the right thing to do because
i've got this barrier that completely
changes the
the strategy you have to
apply things are just not punishable
anymore you just have to accept it
they're just grown
bars that you just have to accept trying
to snipe
interest in that the rob tag won that i
mean i've been priest is probably
thinking yeah as planned
intended
oh my god awful mix-ups mate will just
super dash into your face oh my what is
tacos are the superior
i love the uh
being thrown out
just to cover that space in the six h
actually to bring cell right back in and
boy
here we go good
[Music]
i actually think it's going to be a kill
super boring any drops because the ex
penalty is a lot shorter now we'll fight
gold
mixed mix oh wait wait i respect it
you're a better player to me let's do
super dash
again
i'm still stuck on that lecture
not to go for it now pumping priest has
another chance
at life
[Music]
you don't take every opportunity you get
and there you go
even
pumping priests with baby tohan
rain straight away super death doesn't
connect after the tolhan assist
unfortunately
oh couldn't block in time
oh this is slippery gaming dunk
what you actually saw there was
so baby baby these keyboards don't come
back on bro so even though the key blast
went past
and there's a good point you bring up
because that's uh unique to fighters but
6s does actually come back on block you
have to reflect it so maybe that might
be an option for pumping freeze to pull
out later when the baby's on point
peace out nice knowing you to anyone oh
no we mummy in the bar for this kill
actually
does a lot of damage
he didn't build enough though just about
alive but still no sparky
oh actually one
i love
exponentially for it but
finish the combo
40 seconds left in the clockwise season
yeah we're playing we're getting our
money's worth
had put humphreys down to their last
character
but 39 seconds left on the clock one hit
will actually put pumpkin priest in the
lead but like said not looking to give
him
the
yeah i opportunity the hp lead might be
an elected favorite oh it's definitely
now he's in their favor i don't know if
they're gonna kill from this there's 20
seconds on the clock it is looking
pretty bad for
the priest right now you might want to
pray and hope for a comeback it's doable
we've seen it today so far super dash
doesn't hit 10 seconds left hurry
hungry if puppy breeze does get a kill
it will reset the timer
we're going to get 10 seconds okay it's
going to go back you have to get the
kill now spend the meter go to the one
[ __ ] free system you're gonna have
ten seconds jump down all of these
characters have to die right here right
now
jumping up jumbo jump you have to you
have to go
[Music]
was one more reset one more recent
ticket for lexington but honestly i love
to play from alexia the fact that alexa
had sat back and said okay the timer is
against you it's me it's you i and it's
a timer so you're fighting 3v1 you have
to make a decision really nice though
yeah that it was really good like
patience for elixir just to play the
clock you don't see it too often right
people go there's more than one way to
win
all fighting games you can win by doing
the damage or you can win by having
enough help from remaining uh and then
elixir just had that game plan i think
from when it was like 30 seconds uh the
reason i'm saying just jump for a jump
throw throws because your initial
reaction when you want to keep the life
lead is jump back
yeah jump back so it's like you have to
jump right at this point you've got
you've got 10 seconds to kill this
character and 21's got a lot of options
and it's really good mobility but 1.3
still in it is still first to two i
believe until the four so yeah
let's go leicester's actually raises a
good ball in the chat and maybe
something pumping priest is going to
think about after the tournament
with a short dr yeah that's
that's something you don't want to think
about but if right now
you don't want to think about this
problem because boys are going to hurt
oh
no didn't have any assists didn't have
any assists on deck
this is already gone
right with the
yeah there's probably an empty vanish
confirmed there
oh no oh no pumping priest
and this actually could be heartbreak it
could be a kill we're gonna see level
two
then level one then level three i think
you're just about alive
confirm as well assist into raw tags mr
perfection is in the building on his
stage as well he gets an extra power up
no one knows
oh wow
right now you're gonna get mixed for
with the overhead
and honestly going for overhead there
again
because he has like 64.85
i
i like the upbeat you know what i
haven't seen in so long other than like
the
okay
oh my
god it's never ending
oh huh
traders you why pay to win
let's keep it real
four night line
what
that works that's pretty good i don't
know why i thought it would
um but oh no
the block the lucky drunk
[Music]
looking for swings here the sneeze won't
connect vanish on vanish
here comes the baby shower
oh tagged really loud for that yeah it
couldn't really get a mix but didn't get
tired and safely not much health and
you're going to get sniped by the assist
taken upstairs by your father brought
back down you're grounded
brings in the wench who is 21.
[Music]
this is
worry time when you're starting to worry
you have no sparking as you'll come back
with down the character there you go
much me into suspense
and look that is i was going to talk
about this as well uh 21's keyboards
rounded keyboards cannibalizes other
people so you have to be so careful
throwing them out great knowledge from
alexa have you with this level 3s guess
guess what side they're going to be on
same side high
you're right
i should play more tonight
speaking of getting hurt
i'm increased taking a lot of damage
vanishing advantage
i'm doing the face income still
and change change
yeah they're rotating through characters
really quickly and this only benefits
pumping grease right because he's taking
[ __ ] damage away from these characters
making them all one touchable that's
exactly what you want
not gonna build one bar needed
oh my goodness what a brave trap you're
right yeah sorry my bad i saw that
completely wrong your third eye
went for the hug afterwards
look at the fiber afterwards oh my god
[Music]
uh 18 and just call that brother barry
stop advances you feel a little bit
closer to the ground though
yeah like that if they want the effect
to really cover into you
oh don't really walk on my block
ready and willing to let it run anytime
because it's perfect that backs away
though
oh he said he doesn't like he doesn't
like the 2v1 but he'll intervene if he
has to 2h yeah your brother wasn't back
though he's still at the shops so no
follow-up
[Music]
connected and the gm will open up
increase i'm sure they were going to
perform
but not enough brains to let it go
through level 1 level 3 should be enough
to get the kill
we have approached the squeaky bomb time
it's 50 seconds left in the club
pumpkin priest has one character left
and has to eat through two
[Music]
indeed indeed barrier oh but we've got
we've got parasites we've got parasites
and like baby being able to use
uh ui's assist but he might not survive
oh no he will fight not in that bar can
you get out of the corner
hit the barrier but doesn't get punished
for it but that jh will be enough alexia
takes it two to nothing of a pumping
priest and will move forward into
losers yeah i mean
that's the second two we've had
i feel pumping freeze did have like a
big chance but
alex is just
a bit too elusive i feel uh
unlike how when we saw nago it was very
back and forth right uh with when their
game plan worked
i think elixir just saw him when not me
i'm not there i've got barriers on deck
i'm gonna just jump around one by a
timeout they had a different game plan
going in and pumping priest
couldn't
pump the accelerator fast enough
couldn't get in
i'm clutching my chest and i'm not just
like goku because
you think back in those games and he
thinks of oh my gosh if i slow dr if i
if i short the odds
would i have had another chance would it
have been one one in that situation but
regardless alex he had moving forward to
lose his semi
and semi's uh pumping priest and i have
to bow out
oh my gosh what a great great
these plays are putting on they're
playing fantastically sure
for sure for sure i think uh pumping
priest might want to send out tweet
blame all the content creators saying
hold down dr the one time the one and
only time when you shouldn't hold down
vr is that three seconds two seconds
left of the game that's when you don't
go for the 30 hits
but it's all a learning experience right
uh yep pumping priest even though they
are out of this tournament they're going
to get some points
because uh they're in top eight that's
guaranteed points i think it's to 14 or
something like that uh yeah i mean
points on the board is great especially
in the master's events which offers the
most points right now
but i believe we are going to be going
to our other losers quarter final
which is going to be jonas going up
against zark and
we saw this
we we saw zak before get very clutch
um
but now you have to pull out against
someone who i think has beaten them
before i'm actually going to double
check this
zark
did not be honest jonas actually went
down no no
honda beat zach um
but yeah definitely gonna have to worry
about the play styles are pulled off
right because that was very fast very in
your face
and but that's the with this team right
with kid boo the durian with 21. boy if
you get if you have to block
good luck and there's no there's no
reversals on this team either there's no
actual true reversals apart from
obviously level three um
when when you have to block against this
team you have to block all spark so dark
has to be a monster neutral i feel
honest gaming
[Music]
confirmation we take it damage is
damaged
and the corner
deadly
mids i mean it's a left right by me
can we put back in corner please no
don't win it
yeah
honestly i like this no take no damage
and you look to fight another day right
you're not gonna get too touched
and there's a spot on
dark side
here's your turn start the momentum goes
for crosstalk good block from zero
jump js into a mix and that jl will
connect
goes right back on the offensive office
all staircases no elevators
don't be lazy
dash jab
no one's home yeah the jump next is a
definitely something
so grimy these ieds are like inches off
the ground inches off the ground i was
going to say that's so low i'd never
expected you not to be able to get mixed
and i'm sure zach didn't think the same
thing
no no it's not going to take the first
character and i was going to say bring
in jiren because jiren versus virgil is
a field thing jiren cannot jiren can
really really stop this vegeta's
momentum you can't use split finger
shots as you wish but i think darth
recognizes that obstacle esports kicks
but nice
my caramba
6m gets blocked gonna have to pull
something out of the bag if you want to
hit
mr zark right now he tried to hit the
fade away and it didn't work and now
zach
is turning defense into offense
perfectly with seven bars on deck
spend
that needle let's go
we don't scrimp out here number three
comes out and because you have three
meats in the back if you do get hit this
character should
[Music]
it's a better question
brave brave people
oh
belongs to both of us oh my gosh that's
just too much it's too much too much
i think zag actually does get zenkai
booster the more characters lock seems
to lose the stronger they get
respect
i was going to say if zach can get them
out there's a lot of blue life available
no 2 h on the raw tag it's going to be
reflecting
are we gonna get uploaded as well let's
find out what's it going for
super jump bit more extra damage i like
it right this is
it's acceptable it's top head acceptable
online friendly combos but i appreciate
it do you vanish of course yes
that is
you know whatever i hear people say you
have to deal with i look at that and i'm
sick
but the house like
is tech again so you can dash forward
i
booking
that
and dashboard um
but it's risky it's very very risky it's
sort of a guess and it's something you
shouldn't do unless they show you
otherwise but right now two characters
to one but it's jiren
and that should be enough i think jonas
is gonna go down as long as zach can
deplete this combo
finger lasers
one up against jonas
fairly convincing i think at the
beginning of the match it looked like it
was back and forth and then
it clicked
and uh zach just went oh yeah it's time
to win now and uh yeah from the raw tag
it was looking looking pretty peak for
my guy
uh but again only the first round we've
seen it go back and forth and a lot of
these matches earlier on being two one
only a couple of the two o's so
still anyone's game especially when
you've got kimberly man you are the
variable yep i was going to say kibbu is
a character i think a lot of people
have considered to be
very strong for a long time
despite concert attempts to put him in a
grave
he keeps going back
yeah z nation bro he's definitely part
of z nation you can't keep this guy as a
man you can take away all the grime all
the basics takeaways to touch this
character's always gonna be
take strong my two top she can take away
my damage
i'll take away my mix mix mix and that's
exactly what trippy is saying right now
let's go
pinned down yeah doesn't knows the
procedure doesn't want to watch his
rerun he doesn't have dave
oh
ex
[Music]
not the expert forces just exp rules
football is not plus
it's not plus it's definitely negative
but that's how scared we all have
irrational fears some people spirit of
spiders some people you know scared of
heights some people scared of ex bull
into something they don't want to see it
some people are afraid of 21 minutes of
rightly so
comes
that's a real friend that's practical
beer
all the fact that's all right
buns chop five croissants
oh my gosh
that was that was a very heavy one that
was that was heavy meat that was a chill
meat
i don't think he's actually gonna kill
him like killing a fight
i know people
sort of they think themselves five h
looks very similar to the smaller so i
can understand why you might get here um
[Music]
yeah man
the count is also very real i'm gonna
say you know something big if they want
to make this comeback it's really cute
jiren definitely the equalizer
wow
good defense is a good offense same side
super dash
season one are you calling is that you
you want your mix back
it's the same size
we haven't seen that yes
the worst thing is i play as a jpg
that's a little live oh i don't have
stuff like this but it looks like jonas
does on the big stage trying to bring it
back with the two characters
stomp two feet
[Music]
and look at the escape man it's floating
like a kite run
like a car you're frail get smoked by
the cross up tail normals once again
doing the damage
i wish
it's fantastic i love the way they're
treated to navigate neutral and also
navigate out
disadvantaged situations also the way
they're dancing on your next head right
now um
it's pretty good too
like that yeah
[Music]
has your trainers in store come collect
come collect but jonas only has jiren
the only person who's got
he's got a vehicle to get to the mall
let's see if you can clean up here
yo teleport to get out of the corner
resources
but also the command grab
and with one and a bit of meter we're
gonna see level three just get side note
down
blue assist oh that's what it's like
that's strange i've never seen that
before
yeah i wonder what they're going for
maybe
i'll get you out it's gonna hurt
menacing
[Music]
convincing me as well very convincing
always look like they had control of the
set never really looked like jonas um
was doing enough
sort of threatening it seemed like zach
just had the pace over and over and over
and over again and they'll move forward
to fight alexia see who will be going in
to lose his final
but that's gonna be our loser side setup
i actually think
i actually think we're going back up and
lose the side set up it's going to be
alexia going up against yonah is going
to be going out but like you said before
that's points on the board so well done
to them good showing in the master's
event and hopefully we see more of them
but the next one we're going to get up
it's punder going up against poncake to
set up
what would be our top four right
loser will go into this final and play
the winner of alexia um against zark
down there but i want to say something
people we had
six germans oh this time yep yeah
at the start we are now down to just two
and that is very worrying for any german
fans out there you're surely rooting for
your two remaining representatives in
plunder and zark but poncake and alexia
the fighters from just outside germany
then in denmark and sweden they'll be
fighting to take the gun
[Music]
yeah so that will be top four i believe
that's gonna be first of three but
before we get to those matches we're
gonna take like a five minute break
go get your refreshments drink up
hydrate get food get comfy we'll be back
for some more dragon ball z
eu5
area four or four giveaway rounds i had
it written down but then i smashed up
everything in the back when i tried to
play
anyway look we're gonna have six matches
regardless just come back in like five
minutes
please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back
ladies and lurkers boys and boomers we
are here with top
four of dragon ball championship to
catch you online master challenge i am
one of your shout casters santa mad
esports uh c4 iq aka not tyrant to my
right i have sir
dunk as a guy my dude pulling for judy
in this top four boys it's been a blood
buff
um i i
don't know who i think is going to win
but my heart says
you know one of these four players is
going to take it in emphatic fashion and
it'll be a great final whoever ends up
this youtube
i couldn't call it couldn't call it like
you said uh it was stacked germany and
now there's only two left remaining
pound cake holding it down and blinks
also
got knocked down from luther from
witness to losers but uh
still playing really strong that we've
seen right 2-0 over our uh pumping
priest uh it's going to go up against
zarq a little bit later first we're
going to get pundit versus poncake but
before that we need to see
what these players are
fighting for i know productions are
going to whiz that up right up
and show us the points
or what they're playing on and then the
points yes there we go
so yeah 200 points on the line for
winning this first place will receive a
bag of money in terms of climbing up the
ladder to make it to the regionals a
second 150 third 100 and obviously from
then on it's diminishing but everyone
that you've seen in the top eight is
going to get a substantial amount of
points
so still a lot to play for
commiserations if you're not sitting in
the tournament but still walk away with
something making that climb
but yeah like we've said earlier in the
stream 200 points
compared to the 100 that you get from
the community events
it's such a
strong lead you can get
and
playing catch up is very stressful when
you're at the top you can kind of relax
a little bit you still gotta you know
perform and whatnot but it's a very soft
cushion that you can get and it's very
uh comfortable
when you go through such a stat bracket
like this one and come out with a point
so it'll be interesting to see
it is your four best results right so
even if you enter eight different events
it's your four best results that are
going to be counted so just having a
result in the 10k master event is gonna
be fantastic and we have a lot more
coming up so if you haven't registered
for any of them make sure you venture if
you're rto uh make sure you apply to
make your event a 10k each event so
other people can get points from those
two
i believe we are just about ready to get
into the mayhem that is gonna be winners
final it's prone cake going up against
punder and boy are we going to see some
kid bizzle today
invisible is back i
have a really weird mind and really wish
these two refused so it'd be pundi cakes
i think there's a really sick name for
some reason
there is not going to be any fusion
there's only going to be combats
there is going to be violence there is
going to be evil incarnate on point for
both interesting uh
pun cape going for a assist and it makes
a lot of sense it's a bit of a throwback
but what he backs
uh
with the ui and the adult gohan makes
perfect sense utilizing that block sum
very well punder going for more of the
neutral assist got a little bit more
cool down as well can't be spamming that
beam into full combo but again these are
both point characters so let's see
what happens at the start
here we go
bring them down
i was going to say poncake has a
lockdown hazardous
but does force the spot
bringing the man with the good posture
and then brings him 21 for the mid mix
and the last word is mix i think here
here we go doughnuts yuck stealing
yeah pumpkin thought the same things
[ __ ] wild says don't turn me into a
donut again it comes to make some good
block out from pudding no sparkling so
you have to hold all of this and put
them in
knew that was trying to reset their
pressure during that and because this is
confirmed very very easy should be a
kill
dunk is very afraid of lying right now
level one it's gonna do a lot of damage
oh wow this is not season one by guy i
know yeah it's close let's close though
oh no no no no no
allow it oh no no no no that's a
throwback and a half jesus
oh you need insurance for this gohan
yeah yeah he's going to take a bit of
damage not too much he's only a little
bit bar but in comes kid booth
oh
oh he's cycling oh my gosh unicycles
just going through all the characters
everyone's getting a cameo today
right in here comes the mix with the kid
the x-leds
oh my gosh never ending oh
delete
i feel like a lot of the hits from both
of these guys have been from just
reference
like they're both
sort of going into the first of three
with like a oh i'm gonna get out of this
offensive track
and i guess it's it's okay to have a
first three you know you have a lot of
time to
get used to your opponent
yeah not 100 i think it might be because
of the pressure that both of these
players are mounting it's just like damn
i really don't want to be in this
situation so i'm willing to bail when it
gets to flip but they've both been good
at baiting that right and
i mean 20 watts but not going to do any
more bait in
this game as ui spider-man off the wall
takes
[Music]
after the two so difficult to get i'm
sorry yeah
oh my little bit of rain
oh
wow we dash up and look at me and we
just back away bro oh my gosh my legs
bring all the boys to the yard
and they're like reading books isn't
gonna help you in this combat my guys
seven bars on deck wonder are you going
to take this out of gohan i don't
he's level four enough here i don't
think it will be
i'm going to say no but i'm basically
being a gambling man
no doesn't have to spend it oh gosh
it jumps
[Music]
looks like the tech so you see a lot of
players trying to take it with beyond
poke exposed
be
[Music]
yeah definitely uh
definitely uh an updraft there
see things we don't want to see
illuminate exposed by dunk himself black
dash five cameras
are dangerous
nerf mints
oh my gosh i've hit sss
fingers oh you're sucking
what you got to do about it
your son is being hit by your son's
father his uncle
no that was a combo
okay apparently you're safe on which we
love safe and with stuff
oh it's two bars for that to gather
pressure he's just gonna do it again
get some momentum coming forward that
has to be so careful any keep lost
should be enough here comes the mix
good block on the cross up js
[Music]
get him the biggest
[Music]
the forbidden one that's going to be
pound cake going up one to zero
i'm the geo2h is actually one of my
favorite numbers my most favorite normal
to see in the game 100 it's just so
gasps when he does it he just does a
flash kick that's that's it without
charge i think that's why i like it so
much it's a flash cooker backdrop that's
that's so sick
uh i need to see more of it there's
something about like because i really
like characters who have like a actual
anti-eruption so if you don't have one
team
[Music]
i love seeing people use their 2h
because that means they knew exactly
what you were trying to do
and they called it out with all five of
their fingers but right now poke
one up
remember it's first of three so you
don't just win this one you need to win
two more and daddy going on the
offensive have you seen it oh my god
we've got ssj goku and cooler i was
about to say he's got cooler on his team
but he's got ssj and speaking of
favorite moves my other favorite move to
call out his tattoo making tsubuki
hopefully we see it so i can say it
really loud on the right everyone get
your ears prepared but before that we've
got to deal with this kid food pressure
it's a dragon rush poncake going down to
the new squad that pundit ring to the
table
it's way easier to say if you share it
everyone in chat as well make sure you
share it i want to
i want your parents to know that you're
watching dragon ball love to be ashamed
of all by getting hit by this might not
be shameful now it's not cheap don't
forget we will get grabbed it don't
worry about it the only human future i'm
here to show you what you do not have
this command
actually with that recess
shipyard will not fall look at that
three parts a kill okay
taking the lead here
we are not gonna see any
[Music]
at least this round anyway but we're
going to get it leveled up
uh gohan for potential he's being
unlocked
slowly but surely
as kunda tries to navigate
he's kidding his vanilla could be in
i had to say that was a great block on
between hula brought cronkite down and
it was so ready to block it to end but
not ready to block that law assad i see
source because i do believe it's
dripping off
oh
that's a little
right
again
i don't think it hurts oh that's a drunk
combo we can't have that scarlet someone
thinking oh come on my guy
mind your net back
the ghost of scarlet just behind
what are you doing from 4k two
characters up the team changes actually
make things worse always for thunder
bouncing
[Music]
a round trip
just to get to confirm
but taking to the corner here comes kid
boo
concave with the whole squad ready
tailed normal's always hit by having
haven't been ready for the confirm keep
going back to that world that cross-up
james the jm just hit james was actually
unblocked in case you guys didn't know
cooler jm is just unblockable at least
in this game right now punder definitely
finding a way to open up oh
you said such a big big start i mean
even coming second 100
that's like winning one of the other
tournaments so
uh definitely nothing to turn your nose
up at but
you know you never really want to drop
out of losers i know it's and silly
right you always just want to win win uh
dropping out loses here knowing that the
two people down there are gunning for
your spot
gotta be nerve-wracking man gotta be uh
gotta be a little bit scared of that but
sticking with the team
like ssj goku belief
yeah i love to see right believe in this
team and i think it's good intel going
forward into music if you do end up so i
do like this from tundra
let's talk about this match because
right now
on
just jumping away avoiding all of that
claw that couldn't take trying to fry at
them yeah just weighing it out whether
in the storm but plunders in
dead
slight exaggeration slides
not dead dying i think is a better way
to play right with so much meter to
spend
this is gonna be a rush spot level one
are we gonna see never want to take them
out of the corner like this and level
three to put them right back into it i'm
not sure if because of how far they let
the
[Music]
all
that should be their character poker
evens up the characters very quickly
pancake use all of the meter that they
had i'm very sad we aren't getting many
spots
yeah i i miss honestly i mean season two
i literally forgot that that character
had that move so i didn't see
it fired it's okay
one cake still in the toilet even if
they do lose but that's clearly not what
they want right now as they go in cooler
bp good tech there
poon cake alert ready third eye open
like you say
fade away
yeah it's not much help with your third
eyes open if you're two eyes back
they got hit by the same side in js
aggressive bars oh yeah
oh stephanie this guy is violence he's
gonna throw the sun at him this
character is crazy completely
unnecessary son by the way
not necessary
could have left the sun in the back
pocket says okay i'm gonna show you
what's good
okay
the last cooler
cosplaying is brother
oh my gosh
step on me not one of those stream
please
confirm with the chase up
might not see me next week or tomorrow
don't worry about it you know what
that's the jacket forever but paul
king's gone
one thing i know about pundit now is
they're on fire
they are they are only as soon as cooler
comes out it's like okay i'm going to
begin the
the ted talk it's about violence because
stepping aggressively on the character
yeah
this this character is war just yeah
he's i'm good i might have to start
calling kratos he's on crutch
all the time bruh like every move he
does is
maximum carnage like just devastation
you don't want that character
to i don't i think the way punder plays
you don't want that to be your anchor
because he he's just gonna throw
everything at you is he's a caged animal
if he's back to the wall you don't know
what he's gonna do so unpredictable and
he's execution has been really strong
with him so far
oh that was good confirmed no j2 hates
though to get more cocaine goes back on
the aggressive gets mixed from oh
but that is i guess uh wanted to take
their turn back with the five else get
hit by js
trying to stagger our first this great
tech there from gundam
yeah has a little bit of atheism on that
confirmed rather too or hit but then
went for a dragon rock wasn't ready but
in comes mr violence it was him officer
he did it
yeah exactly
you're gonna need to see a dr as well
bro after that oh take him to the ground
flex
there we go level one what we got cooler
are we getting out you're staying in you
want some hope where you going don't
back away from me bro
oh my god big whiffer
yeah you're probably right actually
and if we see
the moves coming out and that might
actually no wait look
[Music]
but you're a fair player to me you made
it work anyway it was obvious three hate
chimpanzees
but now cooler likes it more because
you're not blocking that means he can
put his feet on you
oh no he's gonna put hands just hand
just hands oh my gosh show me that no
eyebrows
you flexed up thunder and he took it
personally
not happy about that and now they get ok
right now
oh my gosh you are big foreigner else
that's your mickey
dragon
dr wikiboo
no whoa abstract mix with that j2h
yeah blocks of beans plasma on screen
pancakes holding it down firmly
reflecting when needed to blocking when
necessary good block on the two and
cross under spot don't want to see it
dashboard there but we'll get here by
the 5h
is this coming back
get do some damage and that's gonna be
level three waste all of that here one
sparking
honda can you block this one out to keep
your ssj goku alive
talk to the corner you get the next one
i promise i won't say nothing no
[Music]
oh no he's too small it doesn't work in
him the only way you can beat kibbu is
making blue broth
six four match up
yeah so crucial right
that went straight to the gut
that ep went straight to the gut and
with
gonna spend three of it
and okay
i have to get it right here comes the
mix
whoa
shaggy
[Laughter]
is brought back away mid mid
again
i like it oh he is freestyling parkour
parkour mix up hold the dp
team vanilla bruh
honestly i don't think any of us saw
this coming but
we
he's doing a sick job and turning this
round we all kind of doubted him when he
lost right when after the team changed
but he's making it work backfist
watching netback wasn't
ready and now
okay might bring this back
what a good
stronger cisco
sliding knock down safe jump
on violence right now for it i'm all for
it i want to see it bro more fire more
fire more tattoo makings bro i've got
this guy already but i i
unders i don't know why they
deserted this team from the first game
they're clearly super strong with cooler
like
and their ssj goku is coming into form
right
you're smart i can understand why their
first team exists because it is a good
team
but sometimes it's not about how good
the team is in general it's about how
well the armor fits you and right now
that cooler armor is his emperor's new
clothes it fits perfectly right now and
punder showing us exactly why this team
is coming out
hopefully they didn't leave until too
late but like you said it's 2-2 all to
play for
200 points in both players graphs just
need to win two more and this is the
start
keep doing kidney violence the super
dash don't you press the s button my guy
wants to keep
the oppression going five o'dlay and go
back to new zealand
uh oh happy boo boo time but can't keep
cooler in [ __ ] faded for punder
that's a trade that i'm sure punta will
take could have been a lot worse
we're in there super nice oh my gosh you
squeaky
oh oh great super dash you have been
wrecked like a boxer says no more of
that in my vicinity supernatural
straight through that js and look at the
meter
look at the damage that's gonna come out
level one into level three look at how
this was every single hit is and boy
this is getting to the game and watch
your sparky if he does expired kick it's
gone
jesus
take the wheel
he's still pressing buttons
this is way this is what it looks like
when everything you do is plus
this is a mindset of i am always plus oh
my goodness
cheese and rice he is going in punder
level three hold the supernova again are
we going to we're going to mix town
where's he getting all these samsung
that's the question
that's the best i need to put shades
but clearly not necessary that dr should
be enough to put away mr violence lord
cooler himself
level one into level three don't even
waste don't even think about saving
enemies right you need to get rid of
this cooler because that's where all of
the light sources coming from from the
right now
2v2
due to scores winners finals first of
three
they come down to the old guard versus
the new ssj goku ui battling it out
believe in the two m please don't
don't be an atheist when it comes to
your normals you're the british
oh roots oh dude that was sick because
they went for the jm to extend realize
they didn't hit and then went into level
three i think they they were holding
like batman or something that's why they
ended up also down that's what went down
back to the level three but it's gonna
work out punder
so close to ending up in grand finals
just one character stands in their way
stackers
say
[Music]
do it for the ground
yeah get some space though oh plays
respecting i say respect i take that
back i'll take that back raw tag in
comes incarnate
evilness kid boom i like the idea of the
reset better
and they're gonna get this level three
one mix away from going into grand
finals can you do it
did the team swap
lost one and the only op there was no
other option he literally pulled a 16.
he had no other option he's like i can't
lose i'm 2-0 down i'm sticking with his
team
and we're going to get this done
grab and honestly that's why it's so
good to have another another sort of
notch in your book another team to go to
punder realize that team wasn't working
and to be fair bro the first team lost
the first game was happy to stick to the
team and it brought him to the dance
baby you're going to grand finals and
you're fighting for those 200 points
boy
that is
still thing because he pulled out lord
ruler you made him look like a peasant
in the first game and then they brought
it back
yeah that was uh
i mean the score line doesn't show like
the run right obviously because it was
wonder was two down
two down went to the main squeeze cooler
and everything changed the goku was
really strong as well the kid born point
did what was necessary takes it just at
the last stretch knocking poon cake like
you said in the losers final he has to
play one of the killers in semi-finals
right uh bundar gets to chill for a bit
sit back enjoy the matches hopefully
like everyone else in the chat is uh
ah man
yeah punder is is out here
germany should be really proud of uh
their performance today
absolutely brother
what great resilience right because they
were down two to nothing and what what
great result is to bring it back even
though some of those games look bleak
punder showing that you should never
give up
and
it works out but we're gonna slip right
down into losers bracket we're going
back to first to two alexia going up
against zark
one of these guys i'm looking at you
and this one should be a barn burner
result as well alexa showing off the
18-21 1821 ui team i believe which i
think is a really really good team um
but zach
talk playing i believe blue goku
i remember blue goku i remember vegeto i
think it's 21.
horrifying um so that should be a great
game between them um
but give us just a second we'll get
right into that to lock in your top
three remember winner of this goes on in
to losers final and has to pay the face
pone cake and the loser goes home bows
out will no longer have a chance no
longer be in the running four
you're region four's next top model
damn i should have ended if i if i knew
that was the uh the snakes
but the great something i said earlier
top four isn't all first of three uh
semis
or semis depending where you're coming
from semi's finals will not be first of
three first or two it's only top three
that's first of three so yeah i i
cleared out my bad production whispered
into me he said you're wrong don't be so
stupid the right information
and then i'm gonna pass on to you guys
if you're wrong again
you're welcome
we have we have really nice production
action today
shout outs to our production
person today
hold it down damn c2 now you're not even
wrong
c2 tyron voice mod indeed indeed i'll
hold that title
someone has to be right
all right lose the semis this time
alexia is going up against zark
what's your thoughts on this matchup
people i want to know i really want them
things
shark's pressure is insane but
alex's
part of movement has been really good
when it needs to be right when there's
uh
when they're playing for that life lead
they're very slippery so i don't know if
zack's going to be able to get in that's
going to be the tail of the tail feel
but starts super
scary oh that was a bay and zog didn't
get hooked we'll get him back
to confirm five volts of dr
i say
smashed out on him
to get people's attention do you want a
job commentating
yes i do
here's all my information you're not
gonna go anywhere you're gonna have to
listen to my elevator pitch talk to me
not to sit too close to your own
commentary
the barrier i think i wasn't reacting to
the barrier that's a really good cooler
five m mid mid
chassis damascus mid mid mid just five
m's
oh my gosh but look at that 21 bleeding
in the back you cannot get hit right now
if you're alexia
oh no whoa
oh just snatch up don't don't stop at
all i know you want the black people so
hard you want to bring 20 on in you want
to get rid of that blue health
dude
the brother
and now you have to guess no sparky you
do have access to the anti-air command
grab and
i mean i did not expect to see back
dashes done so much in this game and
i've been playing another game where
they're very strong but i mean zac is
making it look very very threatening
right especially with the geo because of
the 5ml it's such a big threat
crispy creams
delicious just like the sparkling
alexander is going to have to hold on to
oh my god oh my god that was so not a
mix it was
unblockable unescapable it was
guaranteed to work it's layer four
because you're like you're sitting there
thinking about one block right right
yeah then you're just like wait why are
they standing there doing nothing and
then you look at the screen and you're
getting hit you've been together
smokes and mirrors can we get another
smoke to mirror come on let's do it
again
i want like i want empty same side
cross-up pin or something like that give
me the fakery oh no we get the real
stuff real stuff
out of this bakery c4 keeping it oh
did you see the exposure that was bad
photography about that was polaroid
exposure there's two l2l just do it
that's really good
[Music]
oh my gosh the best assist no blocks
done
it's mid super sick assist very very
strong
blue hair
oh
that was basically unblockable that's
that's nice and
intentional and fair and that is going
to get
the win 21.
elected
one up in this first two
zark was looking very strong at the
beginning oh the happy birthday i did i
forgot about it oh no wait no ah ah i
forgot i was having such a good time and
you brought it back and i'm sure zach is
thinking the same thing because that
would have been two
dead characters
but they did too much
they did way too much lost that
obviously they after this sword because
the sword actually brings them back
together
instead of them falling out after the
sword they could have done anything they
wanted went for the vanishing too many
hits and
yeah in first or two you're going to
rule those mistakes
i am okay i was i was very afraid they
weren't going to see the second game but
they're back don't worry about it don't
panic everyone stay calm all right
take a deep breath in
and out
during uh during the win pose
everyone get into into the lotus calm
down chill be more zen
yep and don't get hit by
the go5m and we can all have fun right
ready
taking to the ground chase the uptick
gets smoked by the assist and no confirm
has to block the ui
assist
elbows traveling across the screen
all delayed
wasn't ready for the confirmed dunk
i was going to ask you what my fingers
smell like but that is definitely
this is definitely not the twitch
channel to be doing that on but i mean
they smell my mix right now oh
same side gets
blocked what game is this
double backpack
okay
i'm going to be see digits by the end of
this stream i'll probably do the masters
it's fine all the air
oh that was kind of clean let's go
i'm impressed
they're playing literally double dash
they're playing mario kart to get out of
pressure it's actually insane oh get off
me oh this is okay i'm pretty sure the
scaling on this became so much better
since you stopped being a bp in fact i'm
going to go ahead go ahead and put on
what you
press the wrong assist
is my addiction [ __ ] it again let's go
oh no don't sneeze with me please
kazunta get issue go 21's aren't yes
it doesn't matter where you are the
community's personally fine
i'm trying not to curse people up but
it's not working i can't cool it
i'm just gonna go back to shade wait i
mean give me some tattoo making some
pikachus don't put them here
[Music]
[Music]
yo we're just puns
windy punches
staggers
the blockage right now oh my gosh
yo 18 was covering it as well
that was across the trailer that the
plot was in the building the blocking
was sweet and it gets paid off zark gets
the clip
jumping low leaving 18 on their own
never alone really has the brother to
work with but i like this from zach's
mother the 18 don't give them a chance
to call the brother
kick the brother even if you want to
know
i think we're stupid
got seven bars here i think this might
be the end of 21.
and that was full screen as well that
was uh
whatever happens take the wheel
and honestly walk out
the god button is here five m gotta be
careful
jumps to this doesn't want any papa
john's today man's on the diet
i no longer like this from zach i love
this one cause he's gonna punish this
with the meat
alex said somewhere getting a point
that should be enough to kill level
three takes it down it's actually it's
not two one it's one one it's first the
two so
[Music]
1-1 um and i honestly i like roy zach
played the end of that game right well i
don't know what 18 wants to do is jump
back cool 17 assists
if you're winning the game you do not
need to go and fight her
she has to come to you
come forward to me and i'll deal with
you on the other side so really nice
patience there from zach a really good
composure it's one a piece the first or
two ends here
will it be alexia moving forwards into
losers finally to represent sweden to
keep the gems down or would it be dark
to represent the home well i'm going to
give them the home sort of advantage so
many of them in the bracket
moving on into luce's final to take on
pokemon
indeed indeed i can't call it man those
matches again back and forth that a lot
of those matches so far
tries to confirm with the assist to
cross up here it's blue gonna take you
wide to the corner i believe they don't
drop the combo shout outs non-cursed
there we go
and this backs off to neutral i like it
i like the confidence
[Music]
oh outback you know your stuff you don't
quite know your combo that's unfortunate
but sparked up
can you avoid no you can't you can't
escape ui
that is 4.99 neutral you take that
here comes my brother and me john cena
makes but
[Music]
right now
oh yum yum no no death though oh
empty lows
and he says the angry must be mad
because
they might get knocked out right now
that i was gonna say need to confirm i
actually messed up by
blue goku again zach in the lead and
happy to play super patiently i'm just
looking for an opening
i like this one
[Music]
yeah just waiting
there was a gap there laddered
underground here phil i didn't see it
mine
i definitely fell through
there's something about who i go for
five o'clock it's actually quite scary i
don't know what it is
oh yeah but 21 is fine even scary
because there's no deal behind that only
buttons only hands and only zoc being
three to one on character zoc looking to
book their place
yeah looking pretty convincing but this
is the lady of the hour
21
known for the grimiest tech mix-ups
approaches neutral
none of that works when you're in the
corner unfortunately
staggers daggers
block on the crusher
like that from the second plot that's
six points to work with anything will do
it actually
elbows past the keyboard obviously
properly property that
does have tries to confirm but
another cross up elbow will connect
level
indeed i think that's all they need
right look at the likely this mahousy on
zak's hide right gonna keep
luka in while don't go gets some tissue
please
nowhere you guys ex-eyes please you
don't need that
two characters to win alexa i'm looking
to pull this one back
tails
good block on the video assist but you
can't
on the verge of going out and this super
dash will be enough zark when i end up
going down
i'm sorry gonna end up going through
alexander go to losers finals
i think you called it at the beginning
right he said it's gonna be a slobber
knockout first or two it's this like
last chance saloon uh that's gonna be
fourth place still some points but
yeah not in the triple figure range
which is unfortunate like we said you're
gonna want that going into uh going into
the rest of the din catchy series
only having your four best results as
your points uh probably this will be one
of them right because like i said a
bunch of points but this does give us
our final free
so zak
battling it out from losers
absolute trooper the the hero's journey
making it this far poon cake and punda
were in winner's side panda's already
been pound cake so probably feeling a
little bit you know secure
in their points but i'm gonna let you
know what's in the royals
plunder has beat both of these players
window is the one that said zach to lose
the bracket right that's the one that
sent home cake to lose his bracket
so both of these guys are looking for
vengeance
when they get back or when one of them
gets back into the grand finals but it's
about who it's gonna be will it be
poncake we're presenting denmark or will
it be an all
german final
bizarre
underweights either of those players and
chat has descended into spaghetti or
pasta yeah it's about zark i mean
he's bound for losers to get here you
know what let me have his mother i think
he deserves his moment right uh
like we've always said like battling
through losers is such a struggle man
having to play twice as many games as
the people
upstairs is uh
it's grueling it's grooming but the one
good thing you do have with that is you
keep momentum your fingers stay warm you
don't get cold you stay you know like
fresh and active to keep fighting and
you're gonna need that when you're going
up against people that are in winners
who had the safety belt and if you can
get to the finals or if he's gonna have
to reset a bracket
the journey basically is just died for
zach so he's going to need all the copy
posters and hopefully he can turn those
into genki dharmas yeah i'm going to
need all the strength of everyone in
chat who supports them
but home cake been sitting in
winterslide for pretty much all of the
tournaments right
uh only went down to punder we see i
think poncake had a really good start
and maybe because there was so much um
much time because that's one of the
negatives of being on winning side right
a lot of the games on this side get
played and while they're staying warm
you're watching them you do have that
time to start downloading but your hands
aren't necessarily as warm as them so
we'll see if punk cake can take it to
zach i believe the players are just
ready to go but oh no they're ready to
go i'm absolutely ready to go we're
going to see zark
take on phone kick it's losers finals
it's first of three now
but these guys fighting for a place in
ground
oh yeah zak a little bit warm
cake from uh obviously coming from a
loss can't be feeling great i lost that
was very much uh winnable on their side
but here we go
beans
[Music]
not about any air attacks because the
two haters on point
dunk oh look at the pressure
one hit away from getting smoked
oh tried to reach up off that jm didn't
quite work out reflected away he's funky
a very far far away game i really like
the decision but i also
he said i look i i knew this was all you
can eat but i'm not into tofu give me
the real meat if you ain't got those i'm
getting out
you don't nuts now now dash that way
dash that way
[Music]
vegan doesn't
and look at the meter build on this
actually it should be enough to kill it
it wasn't enough to kill you all right
there was no lies here did it that's a
different story we never predicted that
it's fine the same though
no lies detective you're a great wing
man thank you for being here
i mean you did open up with that right
so i have to live up to the name the
title one of the the titles i do have
let me stick to one of them
and let's stick to
you know what overkill maybe no i think
you might i think you might actually
need a level three there maybe level one
from
goku there wouldn't have been enough
okay
you got the character
enjoy
actual factories
one up in his losers finals first of
three well with punish yeah that was uh
that was martial arts that was
that was actually
what
yo paul cake snuck out of the quarter
he basically escaped the jail only to go
back to jail said i was coming back
you know when you get sent to your room
you come out the window that one that's
what he did bro he said i'm not grounded
i'm out here oh no [ __ ] [ __ ] out the
window came back through the [ __ ] i
can't be held back
he said i forgot my keys and just
started the engine bear last one
everyone knew you slept out he didn't
care he got the two where he got the
damage and he got the live lead back
slightly in his favor two candles on two
here we go with a neutral again
pumpkin
dynamic movement just constantly moving
and
you know i've noticed something like my
contacts i've seen it has been doing
very well whenever uib is cool
they do the job projectile with 21. and
that's good tech because it puts them in
the air far away from uib assist but it
also takes them out stops the advance
from poking
really nice
i believe you bro what's the uh friend
gun
what
what's happening from the rear with the
eye sharing gun there
get your mix you deserve it pound cake
let's go
don't get grabbed that's all i got to
say because the grab equals death
oh doubles means get a punishment
oh i'm back escape the grabs
and that's jail
that's possible coming out on pinkish
side
[Music]
out of nowhere
yeah and that's that's from dark sort of
conditioning right you seems like jump
back a lot
jump back be patient and then when the
pancake didn't accept it come forward to
yeah christmas 21 taking it bro presents
served up and that's one point on the
board
uh again first of three as its finals on
the loser's side but
zarker
he's making that run man
this is how legends start finding losers
getting into finals
he is just a snowball right now the
momentum he's got is
possibly unstoppable and there's only
two more people in his way
wonder cake i could finally use the
fusion name correctly there are two
people
stop him i'm gonna say the ost choice
for these games
not great but maybe that just means
better game so
you know
oh
big 2m star
i tell you pink's gonna take that's
gonna need this damage
that's away try to shin you
know exactly what's going on now's your
time lizard can you get here
no pancake sparks up and we'll take the
empty vanish combo oh just
i am going to put this normal out here
and if you hit you with your own food
this is a no kid for you airspace
come back down to the ground before i
have to teach you a lesson and the
lesson is take this video
no on banco streams bro you can't do
that
going to force the patch out of them
though doing the cis dr i mean you've
got to be careful bro
you just sparingly oh my gosh
spare him from the realities don't
confirm
out here ready 21
getting
no we're not we're gonna get into the
corner i don't know what's happening
yep i'll go ahead
hold it
fine oh i was gonna see your pumpkin
should be able to spend some meetups
yeah that had zero recovery
and that has zero start that's why it
hits everyone good come on grab dave bye
zark
and another one
it looks i'll just
look at his movement to just
gracefully glide out of the corner but
pancake gets the lock down safe side
dragon rush to jm will connect man
covered every single base like if you
get hit i'm going to mix you if not i'm
going to confirm
so so ready
oh no
it's uh no combo from meter but is this
person with no it's heavily minus he's
got two please don't stuff it
keep it simple kiss
it slightly stuffed
they could have got the kill opted for
the dr to get the blue life i'm not sure
i feel about that but we'll get mixed
jl whip into dr that's going to be blue
goku out here
maybe could have come down to pancake
will take whatever they can get at this
point
oh yeah for sure right i think they knew
that they were kind of like banks of
rights with their happy birthday and
they got slightly lucky so
you know second life and all that
what a crucial dp
[Music]
clutch time we're gonna see level three
here yes we are it's all blue like
damage but no sparking to get back
the car canceled dr by the way i'm not
sure if you saw that before poncake
that's the first time i've seen them
pull it out
oh man
you can't see it didn't see anything i
apologize for everyone's eardrums i'm
sorry
you didn't see it
so i'm gonna continue this game it's one
little
i think
wow there's nothing to talk about that
has intended oh my god
oh
drop drop drop
only echocaster
awful dragon rust though gonna get some
real damage from here six bars spend it
or save it
oh wait you can't
blunder it i'm not sure it might be part
of mix i'm not sure anymore
that's definitely abundant given a grand
opportunity back into this one level
three for the kill it's gonna be one
apiece
yeah i mean
that matched up looked like a lot of
nerves are on the table from both
offense yeah there was a lot of uh
oh i shouldn't even have this
opportunity then you overfall it and
then dropped yours and then
back and forth with
your opportunities as a man like
damascus says but
someone has to clutch out and all's
gotta be one winner per round and yeah
we're going into this first of three
it's looking looking like it can go
either way
has there ever been a drawing like
competitive ever
i've never seen one person i think so
i think this could be the moment for it
you never know but right now it's one a
piece remember this one first of three
so if these guys got two more wins to
put themselves back in grand finals okay
this is a bad way yeah this is about it
man
chad actually i don't care what chess is
it's a backup i'm telling you guys
sorry chad
we're dictating now
[Music]
very very well navigated backs away
still playing so patiently
be able to kill though
level three will be the option next it
will kill zlatan can you block this out
it's five minutes
take your turn back i'll boom here comes
the mix
i mean to be fair five and four m from
blue crew is kind of a war crime
true
that normal potent incredibly true and i
think pumpkin actually
realized they could die
i'm
pretty sure this is dead even though
they
technically didn't get here it was like
a drop blue combo but
[Music]
uncle and father down this is not the
unnamed game that you're thinking of
where you can do that you cannot
oh yes
you're a mad fighter did you tell them
about that because you're speaking about
it at the beginning of the stream
trying to stay alive fighting for his
life
somebody spends and yeah get rid of it
the healing chamber said we're gonna
have 21 on that point here comes level
three here comes the mix and he blocks
out remember dp available
[Music]
that's unfortunate you're going to lose
your out of goalhand probably the star
of the show when it comes to pumpkin
side but they definitely have a ui and
kidney with gold
[Music]
let's see if it's going to be enough
i want a flare
i love it
he jumps
he's a really good man
[Music]
i've ever having a conversation with
another player trying to show you then
tn should have sold it i'm sure he does
it in the uh series
absolutely many times right
at least once
yeah i'm sure he does
all right
oh
[Music]
oh
up jm zark
takes the lead in this one now it's a
lot to concave with the ui goku
seven bar to work with two
so could be could be the beginning of
the sneeze season
windy punch into confirm take him to the
corner you've got so much bar that's a
kick and a half
quick maps
it's been free there we go
[Music]
not sure what clone cake is going to
look for we're going to see a vanish
we're going to see super jump jm we're
going to see no key uh pokey gonna pull
anything out there and start happy to
tech and go back to neutral
and look at these dash blocks here from
cake scheming like a predator trying to
get in safe as possible another dash
block
cross
yeah unfortunately it's hard to i mean
third eye and all that it's very easy
for me to call it
backseat gaming in that but in the in
the heart in the heat of battle it's
hard to see it
and it's hard to see
pumpkin go down like this 2-1 to zark
now
last hit
killed there from the level 3 for go
zach is
i was going to say the exact same thing
so
both wheels on the steering wheel i know
you said he gave it to jesus earlier but
firmly bro
firmly
what's it 10-2 bro good grip he's not
letting go he's one game away
from getting to
to punder in grand finals can he do or
is pong cake gonna play spoiler to this
player's journey through losers bracket
let's find out
two on the screen
and you can see zark have to just sit
back come to me i really like their
decisions in neutral their movement
around contact gonna have to find a way
around it though
it's
expended
i'll be enough to get the first game
number four
for their life right now
oh this is the neutral jump
air
[Music]
yeah
i was saying no sorry i wasn't saying i
was thinking it i say things in my head
i'll talk to myself i'm lonely like that
all good spot we take the blue damage
don't worry about my mental health it's
fine
but this is a good situation with the
pumpkin right get set up has a system
yeah i was gonna say cover the uh okie
the guy cancel out from zach
good blocks misses the cross up though
the band doesn't come out in time but
the pressure is still relevant
and bad dashes i need to up my
has taken a little damage
they're taking a little bit not much
though becomes your key though to assist
on deck as well
bakery with the jumping heavy
dr covered by the assist made it
impossible to see
one here away from dying in that dr will
be enough poke dipping into that well
once again
and
when you equate that to points that's an
expensive dragon rush on kate bringing
it back trying to get it to at least two
two and then think about
the options in the last match but still
got two characters to get rid of right
now but like you said looking very good
but the one in punch what a command crap
that hits if you don't actually hit the
command let's not talk about that
let's leave it out in the ether that's
fair and balanced good jump in though
these balances on point as he perfectly
spaced that jump over the keyblast jumps
away from the elbow doesn't matter what
side you come from
from cake knows
it's engaged back into engagement
comes the mix
out there
and again doctors had a good finger on
the pulse of one pone cake wants to
reset their sort of position
in blockchain and supernatural a lot
we're not going to see left right here
we can see high low but also all the
stills on deck
as
he didn't he didn't care that he was
being offered
him he said no no hors d'oeuvres please
i'm good
i've eaten oh my gosh and i'm going to
be eating a cross up
tail but no confirm well back and forth
over and over
what is happening
teleport out of the way but you can't
teleport out the way of that one
connect
five meter on deck what are you gonna
say
level one into level one
there's the back fist
yo
this movement
[Music]
[Music]
here comes the 21 50 50.
here goes crosstalk pancake blocks it
out
same side super dash
block and the beam will connect straight
into thailand
and this is actually going to be enough
to kill doesn't even need
he's coming out
goku
just saved
set point
openly please
no atheist block strings one two h that
was so high in the sky
he might go to two west same effect all
the ladies get blessed so i'm trying to
bring it back he's so close use the
assist for extension he's going to take
the corner
but not much bar probably going to save
it right makes sense here we go
yeah it doesn't even want to save you i
don't think it's such a risk at this
point to take that dashboard
patiently waiting stalking the
terminator ui
zark trying to keep his leads
oh maybe we went for the ibm windy punch
whiffs
don't give it away
yeah definitely
definitely hit the bus driver
but that was a
a risk i want you to know that was
definitely a respect got hit by 6m and
gave it gave all to god turned on the
bus driver i was like okay cool whatever
happens after this please keep me alive
and it works out zark
has to go to game number five and they
look like they were in control from the
start phone kick says don't count me out
and don't think you're gonna get this
all german grand final on my watch it's
two games a piece we're going to the
last game baby
this tournament has been actually
insanity
this is insanity man the close matches
the back and forth the playstyles the
characters the aggression
zark
smells finals he smells it
loses isn't enough he wants grands
what a switch up on the pace by the way
from zark we've seen them run away a lot
but now it's run forward basis like gets
us [ __ ] and now it's my turn to be
offensive but bring supernatural
they're gonna get their turn back are we
gonna see the level up though that's
what i'm wondering
i think we are we're gonna get the knock
down
it should be c4 actually i don't know
how he's going to get knocked down
doesn't want to go straight to you i
love one smart play than me it chats
wherever you go level one into level two
into level one poke takes the lead zark
has lost the character
mechanic ready and waiting in the back
pocket in addition to four meters
indeed got straight hit the no confirmed
i could be trying to get the long lanky
legs to hit
what if you're speaking about legs
you've got to talk about the geo here we
go he's got the damage to back it up as
well
into fro
we're going to griggs
cupcakes cupcake i mean okay
absolutely right
here comes the mix wowzer went to the
other side low and that's something we
haven't seen at all i don't think from
any twenty one's not pulling out the
clutch rings when he does need them and
now it's two characters a piece
still has the sparking in house
yeah
[Music]
why are you standing up and the reply
was i don't know oh frame kill with the
back fist doesn't connect on anything
[Music]
behind you excuse me
okay you are human thank you because
that initial block was a little bit too
much for me to consider being humanly
possible but here we go level three the
old school one
game of the plasma
where we going
seven
[Music]
to get extra damage off of this
yeah it didn't draw for the keynes
couldn't block him and now i'm going to
take this level three not gonna kill
might use the last bar for a vanish or
potentially probably just trying to bait
the spark here right that might be a
good idea for pancakes you see we go for
talk
it was out of range but unconfirmed and
that the reflect it just didn't work out
i think it tried to affect the deal with
this but it just didn't come through and
now
i'm gonna build so much me are gonna put
themselves ahead here level three will
come out now let's guess for your
character ui goku though has a plethora
of wake up options on deck
too many layers
lasagna mix-ups
that was just the
is one base
away from grand finals one character
away from making this all german
connects with the five l connects with
the jm but neither of them is it is
believed in and now cake has another
chance another opportunity again
connects but not believe him again this
any drops surely this should be it goes
into the vegetable
and zark take a bound
taking it three to two and you've made
this an all german grand final you're
gonna get your run back against punder
[Music]
yeah that was crazy like the the set the
how the tournament is shaped up right
the standing
uh poncake being one of the players and
winners it was just another roadblock
for zach but he's just going through
everyone an absolute tear and he's
guaranteed themselves a hundred point to
minimum
which is which is such a great thing to
do from loser's side to be honest right
uh and how stacked it was uh shout outs
to pancake uh
words from the great tyrant good fight
but good night you're gonna have to go
out in third place unfortunately get
some points by the way tub has never
said that but because i sound like him i
can make it sound like he said that so
we're going to try and do that
propaganda stuff let's go if i'm going
to get fired i'm going to go in the
blazing glory jazz and tyrant
but we are going to get grand finals
great power comes great responsibility
and my responsibility now is to shout
cast this
with mr dunk for soros punder versus
sark the whole top eight with six
germans does come down to two germans in
the grand finals one from losers punder
coming through winners completely
dominated over uh
jonas with one of the only two o's that
we've had right there's only two other
ones that are like that and a three two
of a poncake
but now he has to play the player that
beat pancake but you did say this
earlier in the tournament point that did
beat zach right yes punder has beat both
of the players who were in losers finals
so this is a run back but remember
punder is in winners side you
like you have the luxury of only having
to win one set right zak has to win two
sets in a row not only against an
amazing player but a player that's
beaten already in this tournament that
is a scary thing to have to realize and
i think
zach is going to have to pray that
having the hot hand
is what carries him forward here but at
the same time punder is sitting there
you've seen everything zark can offer
you've seen them fight
tooth and nail to get back here so you
better have done your research and i'm
sure punder
has been
has been absolutely
but boy i have to say
players of europe four i salute you
because you put on a fantastic show a
fantastic show one for us today and we
are going to conclude it with what is
going to be an amazing grand finals
thunder against zach what a way to top
it off
yeah this is going to be
i think like a lot of these matches an
absolute slobber knockout honda's cooler
and ssj goku is just insane to watch he
is
he is all on smoke bro he is just
he's just in smoke there's just no other
way to
he's such a chef
all he cares about is the steam in the
air he wants to cook anyone who comes in
facility of him not even up against him
but zark has shown to be super strong i
hear your gasp
i'm scared and i'm looking
at my discord just in case someone's dna
no no no no no no no okay
i was reading chat and i was like this
is even better shout outs to ace k in
the chat really appreciate this so
apparently zak and punder are training
partners so this is going to be one of
the
greatest grand finals that we're going
to see because it means they already
know exactly what each other
right and this is one of the great
things about watching training partners
play because they know each other so
well they're going to have to pull up
pull up every single stop i am so so
excited to see this
yeah that's super sick i mean
[Music]
it's a very very hard hill for zach but
he's climbed most of it right yep if
he's got this far from losers but like
you said this was the person who put him
into losers now he doesn't have to just
beat them he's got to do it twice to get
those 200 points that is on the line for
first place
a big step up from second place to only
get 100.
there you go c4 it's been a pleasure
flying with you my wingman it's punder
on winning side of grand finals going up
against
losers
i'm going to be unprofessional for one
second in this match but
let's go back to being e sports edible
sports let's see if we're going to get
any more edibles from 21 but right now
the long legs of the law
oh damn you made me cry all right
ceaseful c-sports
whoa
okay
two women to vanish not seen that one
before
i'll have words with any later is that
real right now ssj goku speaking of
getting knocked down let's go
[Music]
wow
i don't know when you're going to wake
up so i will track you
i will track you with this move
so definitely taking the dragon rush
point blank was not scared of the mash
save your chest
there you go save your chest say it loud
and proud
that'll be enough undertakes the first
character
sparking
in the back look not for this one
because i don't know
what was that
what are you standing up for
zach needs to be standing up for himself
because right now he's the only one who
can get him into
200 points for the world championship
but right now
thunder oh with 6m 5m though regain
neutral maintain control sss gets
blocked though
a character we should see a level three
here
wow
that's going to ruin my night because
i'm going to have to think about that
real long enhance
which is really annoying but
right now let's see if hula can turn
this around like he's done in many other
matches so far this tournament what a
block oh my gosh i snitched it was hot
off the side
oh shoot
oh shoot
i mean
those same size stitches
plumbers
we've got plumbers
mario teams oh you're back away all
right we don't want it you see what i
mean you see what i mean by training
partners pulling out himself
that's true that is actually really true
edibles
i've noticed polar isn't even trying to
block it
counter hit both points
few tile efforts
50 50 means 50 50.
guess
or strike back you're gonna get hit
while you go out with a can of hit right
why not
put the doubts on one character we'll
connect with the jh i don't know
the limit rate damage will amplify this
because
as a commentator i'm speechless
song just fell into the beyond it was
like yeah you're gonna fall into the vr
absolutely ready
now it's one touch gaming
i'd say one two three you have one more
chance right and that does have sparky
so if you do see a level three as we are
you can you can't spark out this but
don't get baited
that's all you have to ask for don't get
bad that's two ends oh you're not vegeta
so that
take it up the mask
[Music]
it will be close i like the use of ex to
get even more damage out and i actually
think this is deadly before they die
every last bit no one hit more will do
it wake up number one
yo
tekkers
tick
dragon rush no
counter hit
i got hit two i want to go to finals but
honda
skin off his teeth pulls it back with
the wake up acid rain he said he
literally went
i put my hands up he said put the game
in the back and nobody gets hurt and he
lied because because i got hurt but i'm
not involved i'm not gonna be a part of
that
i am not involved that's sick that's
sick i think that's because if they
cross up you get level three and they
can't do anything about it right oh
you're right but but it's not invincible
right so it should get
can't hit on start
training partners
i tried to think my bad apologies
they're beyond the the matchups and the
and the tech and the characters right
they're saying
what would work against this player this
person this individual
i just read and i regret someone said
level one is just frame eight reversal
who said that i don't know you should
practice
that bad one
or mrs facts shout out to them
oh [ __ ] i'm going to get into game
number two
wait a minute you have to comment your
own i actually got whiplash he floated
all over him
came back the other way
i have to say put the movement out of
the corner
and then punch him
kill the character
even more sick
[Music]
oh you made me feel young
you know you're young
[Music]
that was one of the rare lows we've seen
him oh that was too i'm sorry my bad
when he moved past queen always assuming
their movement is so fast
look they're moving around oh
the punishment didn't turn him around
the game betrayed him
yeah that was unfortunate oh 5s gaming
oh no in cooler brilliant violence
himself
wow
you kind of deserve that my guy you did
wake up 5m i know you're a chad but
chill
oh you're punished
safety
he's got 21 but no sparking seven meters
do you make this comeback you've seen it
before earlier
all right this one will come out
that's double
dash into the command grab and it will
connect
kunda
i wanted the back foot for once this
game
gonna go into level three
you do have mix that panda has sparked
it to keep the team whole keep the team
alive
not to in fact people count here and
that's the third time now so punto must
know something that we've got
um or he's just happy to get something
which is fair it's a 50 50 like you
think
exactly right
you don't get extra damage you can hit
so
go out swinging
but first you're gonna have to hold this
supernova can you have this tails cross
up at the last minute dot-com spot just
to make sure hitting with the plasma
put them in the arena
roadmap
is somewhere smiling to himself thinking
broken did you see that level three mix
how could such a big menacing man move
that fast
he dashed to the other side jl and you
you know look if you're training
partners you've seen that a million
times before but even if you've seen
that kind of stuff the million times
before you just can't react to it
especially in the setting especially in
grand finals grandma right now has given
himself two set points two
chances to call themselves the winner of
this online tenkaichi event all that
stands between him
and victory him and 200 points
is
his training partner
yeah it looks like
zak is suffering it's all like the uk
when it comes to
the petrol i think he's running out he's
he's running on empty man he's had a
long fight
david buzz in in a couple years i just
won't be relevant but right now it's
funny damascus is laughing in the
background i know he is right now
wonders laughing as he's one game away
again 200 points let's see
good block out here you have to fight
back though you have to get out you
don't get any damage from blocking
the move
oh
jumps into the plasma that's the
fortunate staircase and back down after
the vanish
oh
that's unfortunate wasting all that
spark time as well dp chases him trying
to uptech and again
oh my goodness gracious me plunder you
had the book of zelf open since the
beginning of this tournament and he's
looking at the last page he's ready to
write the
last sentence ready to write that finn
at the end
he's got two characters left to deal
with he's dealt with spark but now you
have to deal with the geo and he's five
then the long pistol
[Music]
you
need to be stopped
zark
reeds
your friend apparently your partner
in crime
c4 i want to realize how big this is
it's in grand finals he's down two
police came to his house and said what
happened i'll write my statement here we
go
oh
bonk
not on your main
sweep the toes
and now
we'll end up taking down
the last
the last part of this team and now it's
all up to solve the geo no sparking on
either side it's all fair comeback
chanzang pull off this comeback and save
the set point of warponda solidified
their first place in this online
technique event
oh he is trying to get this guy posted
on twitter
he charged into dragon rush definitely
trying to finger dash block swords get
blocked
it's not jessica it's not that they you
do get delivered
but the problem now is are you going to
get constantly oppressed in this corner
you have one chance i think
good job
jm goes to the vr great tech difference
but you have to continue to fight you
have to continue to hold on the jh will
connect but he won't believe the two
world will come out
and c4
i don't think i'm gonna be wrong this
time because this is a lot of damage
thunder
take a bow
you've beat zark before sent them to
loose racket and you've sent them out of
this tournament
has taken the online tenkaichi event and
will bag themselves 200 points and
they're sitting pretty in europe four
right now
that was crazy man like that last
sequence
they got bopped on the head with a jump
heavy they went for the dr opponent said
no i'm just pressing buttons one hit
on hit
like a great time once said you know
what
when you've got yellow hair you just
don't care you press buttons he
definitely said that i promise you i'll
find the receipt to post on twitter
later but right now let's talk about
punder the winners run
getting
200 points
[Music]
and look at that right so shout outs to
um
zach will collect 150 which is more than
you get for a first place in anywhere
that's right so that's still a lot of
points i believe okay we'll go home with
a hundred so they all got big big big
points but right now the king of europe
four has to be punder
200 points sitting in their bag enjoying
that and honestly well played deserved
every single point they got for such a
fantastic performance in europe for you
put on a fantastic show for all of us
wow
for sure man while we were
that's that's how you pronounce it like
winners always didn't lose a set
didn't drop a set
okay the closest with uh 3-2 in in the
top eight uh and then the person who
beat them went up and
like you said
uh it was pretty i think ponder just
went into it way more confident zac zach
must have been just so drained for all
the games they have to play and then to
know that i have to beat this person
twice in the first of three
like that that's tiring like maybe not
physically like sweating like energy but
mentally yeah the stack is depleting but
chances are because he still made a very
good run and bagged himself 100 points
which is the equivalent to some of the
tournaments that are going to happen
after today so check those out make sure
you sign up and if you're a to get those
permissions from the dragonball fighterz
portal so you can run the 10 catch as
well 100 points if you get a big enough
tournament to the winner and then you
can match up with zak but yeah like you
said ponder
hands off to you my dude done it well
cooler ssj goku in 2021
bagged him 200
wongas points
whatever you want to call them he's got
200 of them he's got more than he can
hold in his hand so he's going to be
happy about that
it's so many points and like honestly
i'm excited because that means a lot of
europe is going to have to fight punder
and sort of make sure that he doesn't
get any more points because he's sitting
pretty on top right now and like you
said before there's loads more
tournaments so make sure you get on that
i'm sure the command is somewhere in
chat so you can apply as a player or you
can apply your event as a to
but that's gonna be all the action from
europe for i have to say thank you guys
for putting him on a fantastic show
thank you chat for putting on an amazing
show in there thank you for following me
so c4 as my roommate and i'm happy to
follow you but guys
don't fret there's more dragon ball
fighters 10k online events coming back
tomorrow it's our regency fall
it's going to be our region the uk
island and netherlands will be battling
out for top eight right back at the same
time eight o'clock we take uk time
that's all from me me and c4
and i guess we have nothing left to say
but bye thank you so much everyone we'll
see you in a
[Music]
bit um
[Music]
ah
[Music]
body paint
[Music]
it
oh
[Music]
oh